Unmute!
Yippee!
Hey guys!
We're all unmuted now!
Let's go!
I've been silenced.
We're all unmuted now.
Okay, we were actually discussing strats because we finally
got the achievements and everything.
But I guess like...
Now we know what we have to do.
So I guess like a small introduction of all of us.
know who we are because we have someone that's not a vtuber
here in our ranks like our little imposter right here oh
that's who i also forced to make the server beautiful sure
for why don't you introduce yourselves sure for i go last
because i'm the special one you're the special one okay okay
all right so hello guys i'm doki aka doki bird I am the
captain, but I made sure for make the server as the captain.
That's me.
That's just pink strats.
Yeah, I'm just like outsourcing.
All right, who's next?
How's it outsourcing when I'm part of the team?
And then I invited you to the team.
Who's next?
Well, you're the captain.
Okay, sure for.
Okay.
but I said I'm last.
Okay, shy Lily.
Don't talk back to the captain.
Yeah.
Talk to the captain.
How dare you.
It's three against one.
I know, right?
I got hands.
What?
You said three versus one.
I got hands.
Shy Lily has hands.
She has 3D.
Yeah, I got, I got loads of hands.
None of you are freaking real.
None of you are real.
You can't hurt me.
How do you know if you're real?
Yeah.
Because I can turn on my webcam.
But I...
Whoa!
AI.
My immersion.
Oh, yeah.
Nice immersion break saying you have a webcam.
Maybe I just put it on my feet, man.
Oh, that's some cryo stuff right there.
Whoa.
For free?
Wait, what the heck?
Alright, alright, try Lily.
Your turn to introduce yourself.
Oh, uh, hi, I'm Lily.
Hey.
Hi, Lily.
What is this?
AA?
This is some AA shit.
Hi, I'm Lily.
I'm addicted to Pal World.
No.
Hello, Lily.
Understandable.
Have a nice day.
My condolences.
Do your parents know?
Oh, oh, oh.
Then what does own me?
What the heck?
No, of course.
Don't tell them!
Alright, who's next?
Guys, don't be shy!
I'm last, though.
We still have to talk about our achievements stuff later.
We can't spend 10 minutes on this.
I'll go, I'll go.
Uh, Hoppy Kompi, my name's PP UFO, slime alien, VTuber in a
human suit, except for all the times when I'm not in a human
suit.
I'm a gremlin with a heart of gold.
Just don't ask me where I got the heart or the gold.
Nice to meet ya.
PP.
pp yeah i got that small pp energy though because i'm like
153 centimeters tall well not very not very tall i have
decided that this is your nickname i'm sorry but you are no
it's acceptable understandable have a nice day you've now
been dubbed pp to the rest of the world hi i'm pp all right
last but not least the flesh tuber okay i have a name you
know yeah but you haven't introduced us so how will we know
your parents hi i'm sure for i used to be an overwatch
league pro now i just stream also known as the rp guy the
battle bit guy league of legends guy congratulations now the
power world guy do your parents know my legacy the gritty
guy yeah my oh he had the gritty guy oh yeah he can do a
match gritty but anyway so we're while we were muted we were
discussing about our the achievements so we're discussing
things before then yeah which was very relevant to our
stream right guys relevant to mine i like the achievement i
don't know if my mods like made a command for it but
basically sure for is going to be our power leveler and then
that's their strats basically that's how we decided that's
the strats sick so we have a power leveler yeah and then we
got this we got this far we got this far anyway we so are we
doing were we doing a global achievements like for day two
right for the extra multiplier i think we just do whatever
we can do yeah pretty much just do can do i think like
keeping track of who's caught what is going to like waste
time so i guess just kind of just do whatever we'll kind of
collect whatever we've done at the only time we need to do
stuff together is for the group achievements yeah we'll be
there for that the group one was like take a team photo in
the wildlife sanctuary and then with the reincarnated guy
and then we have to compete in the ravine grotto dungeon as
well as a mountain stream grotto where the fuck is either of
those yeah i was gonna say where the are these places no
idea you're the one that linked interactive
map i don't i want the what map sorry if there was a map you
should probably hide all the things and then just pick and
choose what you'd want to show up on it.
Sorry.
I mean, the PAL world map, but sorry.
Oh, yeah, the official in-game PAL world map.
Yeah, official in-game map.
Sorry, guys.
How can you use that when it's hidden until you've explored
it?
What?
Whoa!
Where we just explore everything.
Yeah, as long as we explore everything, it'll be fine,
right?
Yeah.
It'll be okay.
We can be fine.
figure this out right we're not exploiting anything we
barely know how to play this game let alone exploit it like
so i think how it's gonna work with the base is that if i'm
gonna have you doing power leveling then i'm probably just
gonna work on resource management and just checking in on
where stuff is and in the meantime just trying to level
myself okay and then lily and i were just exist you know
just next to it yeah i'll do the level up the chicky pea to
level 30 i'll work on that i'll i'll only use a chicky pea
to fight good freaking job yeah i'm gonna put a face by the
desolate church where they've got the uh the ingot like vein
all right wait who wants to catch five humans who wants to
who wants to do that No, you're in base duty.
You're the only one that knows what to do.
Raiders show up.
That's where all the buff men show up, right?
That's true.
Yeah, you can do the...
All right, and you can cook the meat, too, because that's
the base thing, too.
I...
How many steaks do I have to cook?
Just one.
Just go...
Yeah, the Mamma arrest steak.
How the fuck?
So, who...
Oh, Mamma arrest steak.
Okay, I think, like, Cherfor needs to...
Cherfor is the one that needs to fucking kill a Mamma arrest
for us.
You're the power level!
You're gonna be the closest...
to catching one it's chill it's chill i'm being forced to do
so many things what do you mean wait when they say level
level 100 to level 30 did they mean from one or do they just
mean like have a chickpea and it'd be level 30.
no it says level up a chickpea to level 30.
i mean you can probably catch like a level 29 chickpea yeah
up once yeah that's yeah that's yeah but like i feel like by
the time we find a level 29 like i think we should just
level it up by that time
There's like global one was like make a clip where all
teammates are petting different pals of the same element
Does that be like all of us pat all of us petting like water
type or like one of us typing petting water type?
I didn't even fucking pay attention to the global ones.
Oh shit.
There's like breeding as well the new bis and the Oh
Dyermope with three.
I don't know how the breeding things were I mean I didn't
really get into breeding.
Oh, hey if he each person like the amount of pals we catch
is points per person too.
Okay.
Oh my God, one of them is the dire wolf with three move
speed passives.
I had that.
That's just fast as fuck.
So I guess, I guess for the first, for the first hour, I
guess all we should really do is like catch, catch, catch,
and like try to move towards where the base is gonna be,
which is like, if you have a mental map, it's gonna be like
in the red area.
I don't know where The red area towards the tip of one of
those arrows I'm pretty sure it's like towards the south end
of the red and yellow area Alright So basically I don't know
where the fuck That is So I'm just gonna It's by the
desolate church It's too bad they don't have a search
function On the map Yeah it's too bad we're gonna just
Explore that together So we find it right Yeah yeah for sure
for sure also to my chat is everybody sounding okay or is
anybody too quiet my sound guy is afk i have no idea we're
all okay all right anyway so we got our plan right oh
Fucking yeah All right, hour one just Just pump through
Catch All right, nice As long as Our goal not last Even if
we're last place We get $500 So that doesn't really matter
In the end Let's go In the end Even if we're last $500
Sheesh All right, I boosted up Lily's volume Just in case Oh
yeah, I should boost yeah it sounds great here but i'm
looking at the like little thing on obs and doesn't look
great man i'm trying okay boost it up look decent put up the
gain just put it at 200 on discord yeah i did that's what i
did yeah i wish i could turn up my more but i have so much
background noise if i do like i have no my my setup is super
scuffed and like my setup is super like beginner streamer
wait how long have you been streaming a couple years wait
wait what's your graphics card that's it's it's in there
it's in graphics card all streamers are lazy it's a it's
something in there somewhere only do things when they have
to that's true the moment when her pc dies when she upgrades
i wouldn't be surprised she's still using a 60 hertz monitor
are you using a 60 hertz monitor no no it's 60 hertz monitor
mouse acceleration on what's the dpi it's surely more than
that it's surely how when was the last time you bought a
monitor upgrade have you ever actively gone to your monitor
settings and then change your refresh rates yourself okay so
you're not 60 hertz i'm not bad at any FPS games, I just
have a 60 Hertz monitor.
It's not my fault.
I'm actually, yeah, it's not like...
Well, so the thing with 60 Hertz is you're living in
blissful ignorance until you realize.
Yeah, that is so true.
Until you see the light, then you can never go back.
Once you see the light, you get blinded by God and you can't
go back.
I'm not sure if I want God to flash me, to be honest.
Well, it's like a really good flash.
Yeah, it's like a flash that's in your memory forever.
and you can never- Just one time, and then you're gone
forever!
Yeah, and then you can never go back.
You're like, if anybody else flashes me, it won't be the
same.
It's true, though.
My friend is like a pro Valorant player, and they came over
to my house when they were visiting, and they wanted to use
my computer!
And they flashed you?
No!
No, they turned on my stupid monitor, and they were like,
wait, is this 60 hertz?
And I was like, yeah.
And they had gone, like, two weeks without?
And they were like, what's another two weeks?
And then they just walked away.
I was like, are you kidding me?
What?
You're fucking kidding me D&D.
Well...
It's that bad, huh?
Check your herself.
Check your hurts right now.
Go to your monitor, go to your monitor desktop, do display
settings.
Wait wait, wait.
Right click on your desktop.
Yeah.
Right click and then do display settings.
And then...
And then I forgot what to do next.
Okay.
And then scroll down until you see advanced display
settings.
Advanced display.
Yeah.
your moderate what is the refresh rate it says 60 called it
called it now go to your refresh rate and see if you can
change it wait what should i take i was like what are your
options 60 it doesn't matter also i it could 120 143 you had
140 like a legit monitor then yeah yeah so what happened is
shyly we probably bought the monitor is like 6 144 hertz see
now you have no excuse for your fps playing oh everything's
on dark help oh we broke it oh wow whoa i see no difference
there's no way you see no difference she's not even any game
yet of course you can see it with the mouse cursor what's
different on my mouse cursor wait it's more smoother yeah
because it's not 60 frames it has more it has more hurts
whoa that's why i hate 3d cartoons man you're never gonna
get me with that but you and i can only see 30 fps i can't i
hate that comment so much you're like why are you always
complaining about frames we can only see 30 frames for a
second Dog logic All right, they're apparently checking
settings now Sure for you, I'd show that to people Don't
worry, team captain I've already been on it Whoa, you gotta
remember, scroll slowly So we can verify all settings all
the time Just scrolling up and down because they don't know
If they're looking or not
Alright, here we go I can't wait to start this This Pal
World adventure with all of you I can't wait to be dead,
Wade.
Me too.
Dude, I played so much, but I played so casual.
You know, like when you play Animal Crossing and you're
like, this is nice and you go visit your friend's island and
it's just like fully terraformed and you're like, Wade, what
the fuck?
Okay, what's he gonna do that?
Is this a bad time to admit that the PAL World Building Base
Building contest was mostly based on aesthetic?
Yes, because I saw you won a competition and I was like, you
know, know what this person seems to know what they're doing
someone lied on their resume when i was looking for players
when you show up to your job and you don't know what you're
doing oh my god i came with the confidence the confidence of
a of a guy uh like a 30 year old white guy and then you like
and then and then she had all these vouchers underneath and
i'm like you know what people are vouching Surely she knows
what the fuck she's doing people are vouching for her like
she knows surely I do I do I do but I'll also make it look
nice All right, so we don't care there's no points in
whether or not it looks nice There's no there's no Which
face has the most aesthetic there's no which face has the
most aesthetic face They should have that they they should
though we should ask them the Make a rule just for us.
Put that in there.
Just for us.
I like how some of my chat, when people attack the base,
they'll be in awe of how nice it looks.
Exactly.
They're like, whoa, this looks nice.
What the fuck?
They're like, oh my god, we can't attack that base.
Oh my god, look at how much work they put into it.
Wow.
See?
Yeah.
You get it.
See?
We understand.
We just get it.
Alright, let's see.
Are they- I think they haven't even checked us yet, please.
Please.
We just want to join the survey.
Did they come in here?
Did they just randomly come in my stream?
I think they just look at your stream because it says just
scroll up and down until it happens.
Until it happens.
Just get it waiting out until it happens.
Bro, I'm all tabbed right now until they tell me something.
We're voice number six.
How long does it take to get to six?
Yeah, you said this would be fast, huh, first time?
First time.
Oh my god, please, we just want to play PAL world.
Let us in.
Oh my, they should give us names for creative pet names,
too.
By the way, some PALs at the beginning that will be really,
really useful.
If somebody can get that, like, Tombat cat thing, that would
be really, really helpful.
Oh, yeah.
If you can bring that to our base, uh that would be really
great okay why am i going to point it out again because
you're power leveling it spawns it spawns at night in like
the starter area but like mostly like towards like the
bottom of this one hill you see this is exactly why i got
you you already know where people spawn i already played
like three days of power world when it first launched and
then i was done i i have a hundred twenty hours in the game
but i also let my chat backseat a lot so I mean, that's the
point.
That's the point of streaming.
Why the fuck do you do it for yourself when you can just
have them backseat?
Why won't they verify me?
Dang, you sound so desperate.
Stop trying to get verified, Zart.
It's kind of cringe.
I'm so fucking lonely.
I just want the touch of an admin.
Oh, shit.
All host verified Zart.
Dang, this Discord kitten really be out of here purring i'm
not a kitten silence kitten you're on all levels admin
master hasn't approved your presence yet
oh my god all hosts verified start the world and share the
code with you you're not even but we're not even verified
we're not verified yet we're not verified yet well It's not
against me verifying We're in please let us in Let us in
Verified by the way.
It's okay Please we've been looking at the same sure
achievement list for so long
I just like the mental image of like okay once you start the
world you better stay don't stay in the cave here though
like don't don't walk away from there until we start okay
how would they know okay like a desperate preschool teacher
oh that's sure for god damn sure you baited me i thought
they talked in her chat vegeta vegeta and piccolo not a big
fan of the what the is this can this be our team song can
this be your team song yeah i linked it in the team chat all
right sure that people don't hear them.
What?
Let them hear!
Vegeta needs to speak!
It was parental advisory!
Explosive content!
Look up, Vegeta and Piccolo, not a big fan of the government
rap.
There you go.
This is our team song.
This is the song.
My child's like, let him speak.
Let him speak.
I am not I am not supposed to let my chat here it's saying
we're starting in five minutes how do i know if i'm verified
or not we don't even have characters yet how do i ping an
admin to make a campaign come on get that aesthetic at admin
am i verified what the fuck yes oh my god here we are whoa
my discord crashed hello my discord crash when they said yes
I'm verified I'm fucking finally okay I gotta hide the
screen for a second yeah the world name is Among Us Island
nice join multiplayer game alright give us the code sure for
I'm closing the thing and then I'm finalizing where the fuck
do I get the code what do I click we're okay this is bad
that we're all so very confused right now Wait, did you sign
the code in the voice chat?
I don't know what the code is.
Oh, shit.
Oh, I don't remember.
It's been so long since I played this.
I'm customizing my character real quick.
What the fuck?
Oh, my gosh.
Oh, my God.
My Discord crashed.
No!
New down.
Bye, Discord.
Okay, I need to make a new browser, apparently.
Since my Discord crashed.
Don't worry.
It should be fine, right?
No, it's not fine.
Fine.
Okay.
Don't worry, it'll be fine.
I- Oh my god, why are you not showing up on Discord?
What?
I think we need the IP address and then a password or
something.
I don't leak my RP.
Well.
No, three minutes.
Three minutes until the timer starts!
Team Doki Bird is over.
Where do I get the code?
Well, I don't fucking...
Google it.
I don't fucking know.
Check the invite code for this world on the option screen
after start.
starting the game.
Okay.
We only got three minutes!
One.
Two.
Calm down.
Counts down from 180.
Nah, it's chill.
I think a minute isn't going to make much of a difference
anyway.
We're going to get okay.
A minute is a pretty long time.
Yeah.
What the fuck are you talking about?
It makes all the difference.
This is a serious update.
I'm posting the invite code in the team chat.
It is available for everyone now.
Yay.
but also the timer starts in three minutes but we don't
start starting oh okay okay that's not a problem yeah yeah
yeah all right so i can't fix my discord foggy so nobody
will know who's talking now i'm so professional it is i
talkie's mom hello mother all right do we have our code yet
okay i posted it what the frick they're okay i'm how do i
join wait what's the ip we don't need you go to the code one
oh there's a code one yeah yeah yeah it wasn't working in
the first week so i hadn't used it before oh join multi oh
my god there's a code that's what we've been saying team
captain wow yeah team captain you didn't even know jack you
didn't even know what was going on
all right character build speed run Okay, I'm just...
All right, here we go.
Okay, because I have things to have to call him in.
All right, I'm gonna...
I'm gonna show people the game now.
All right.
That looks like me.
30 on 30.
Okay.
We're not allowed to leave the starting area.
No.
We're stuck in our cages.
We're gonna be fine.
So many constraints.
When will I finally be free?
There you go.
In like two minutes apparently.
Oh, then I can talk about drugs?
Yeah, complete.
I'm getting my hair color.
I'm alive.
I'm good to go.
Okay, I might need to look a little bit more healthy.
Roger, Dodger.
Alright, there you go.
Make sure it's thick.
the towers are the key the tree homes wait this this game
has lore I did not know that I just thought I don't know I
just thought it was like pu-pu Pokemon I don't know wait the
timer started wait you guys have to get in the guild first
we have to get in the guild oh my god they started the timer
wait how do I skip this okay everyone hold F on me all right
I'm holding the guild oh my god bro what the heck is going
on here accepted accepted we're so thick i'm missing one
accepted all right i got it we're in go now all right
where's our base what are we doing for our base figure it
out okay what do you mean we're team timer starts i'm power
leveling okay Goodbye, give you 10 wood.
All right, I'll just that wood all right guys.
Let's punch this mammoranth out Let's go.
Yes, we all punch him together.
It'll be fine.
Keep respawning right here.
That's how we get the meat That's an exploit.
That's true.
We all just keep punching it eventually.
We don't even have balls to catch it Like what's the point?
All right.
I'm just gonna need his mead.
We just need his mead All right Where do we where are we
building our base pp?
Well, first off, go ahead and start making yourself some
balls.
I'm making a workbench right here All right, I'm just gonna
punch this lamb balls.
Oh, I need a chicken so I can level it to level 30 Yeah, you
can fight fight one man first so that you get to level two
level two time nice I'm level three, and then you can start
catching people the fuck how are you level three?
What do you mean?
Is our power level or not leveling up?
Wait, what should our stats be for?
Hell, yeah You guys go to technology unlock Palsphere I
don't know but what stats should we should we bank on then
uh for right now yeah for right now if you die just go to
this one but our stats though oh stats uh depends on what
you're maxing I'm gonna do work speed and wait you know I'm
gonna do I think I'm gonna do a wait for now oh shit rock
isn't real what do you mean it's not real I can't punch it
it'd be faster if I just got if i actually just gonna
fucking fuck you all right for a fucking all right all right
nice all right how do i need wood and stone ah and punch
some rocks look at us go we're so efficient sure for what
level are you now our power level uh 32 damn wow if you need
to build a bench you can deconstruct it and get the
materials back what do you mean i hate level two we're level
three What do I need?
I need, uh, I need more stone.
Alright, let's see.
Take that back.
Wait, I needed that.
This is our power, lovely.
Give me my rocks.
Hey, can you build that workbench again?
Wait, what happened to our workbench?
Wait, what's our team name?
What the heck?
Vegeta and Piccolo.
What's that as an acronym?
the government vphtg vphtg basically what we're gonna do is
we're gonna like work our way towards where we're gonna set
up the base and just catch shit along the way nice good just
head towards desolate church if you get lost just uh you
know um ask the gods where it is ask the gods all right no
problem the gods yes the gods let me tab out real quick and
ask the god that's crazy Guys, I can't ask the gods if I'm
in game.
I'm just saying Wild the gods can I'm sitting playing.
Yeah, the gods can know I'm playing it's it's blasphemous me
playing power What the heck no gods don't look gods don't
look I'm sorry.
It's not Pokemon
Legally distinct Pokemon legally distinct Pokemon Let's see,
work speed.
Am I close to...
Oh, yes, nice.
I can build an axe, too.
Don't say the P word.
The lawyers are coming.
Power has been in development for, like, two plus years.
If Nintendo couldn't stop it before then, Nintendo can't
stop it now.
Pokemon?
True.
Valid-based drill.
Preach.
I need more stone.
Oh, crap.
Nice.
I can catch a chicken now.
All right, where's my chicken?
I'll take on.
The chicken's going to be my only pal.
I don't even know if the game volume is, like, okay.
Just a team of chickens.
I'm sure it's fine.
I need to make my pickaxe.
All right, there we go.
Why the fuck is there another fucking...
Oh, shit.
I'm the stamina.
Also, don't forget to get wool.
Otherwise, you're going to freeze to death at night.
So kill some of the little sheep.
Nice.
I'm trying to remember how to throw a pal spear.
Murder is wrong.
Murder is wrong from our pal leveler?
That's a problem.
That's a problem right there.
I don't kill, I capture.
You're capture humanely?
Yeah.
Ethically.
Is it an ethical capture?
How do you know it's ethical?
Is it free range?
Yes, it's free range.
One of the global events is we have to get 20 humans and put
them in the viewing cage oh yeah oh wow that's neat i love
that yeah and he went to catch like five of them earlier too
oh my god my chicken is level five all right let me one of
some free points are just flying around and getting max a
lift monk energy whatever those things are oh shit i mean i
could do that Otherwise, Lymphmonk is not a goal.
There's like 400 of them on the map.
It's a global goal.
It's a global.
So do we have to catch all of them?
You get like 150 points.
Oh, okay.
Oh, we have to get to level 10.
Okay, per person.
Oh, so all of us has to do it technically.
I mean, the gods would be able to help with it, but I don't
know.
Yeah, yeah, the gods.
The gods.
Yeah.
But I can tell you, I got to level 10 doing that, and it
took me like 10 hours.
Yeah, yeah, we could totally do that in like eight hours You
just get a flying you just get a flying pet and then fly
around you have to max it up My little chicken go do their
job Oh my god, there's a chicken rolling down No, don't get
distracted by treasure.
Why do I always do this?
All right, go treasure.
I don't even know are we are we doing okay?
I can't even tell Yeah, we're doing great right are we are
we doing okay guys the first the first hour The first hour
is, like, gonna kind of be a little rough.
It's okay.
I still have my chicken here having a great time.
We're good.
Yeah, I can tell it's having a good time.
I can see its health dwindling, yeah.
Yeah, yeah.
No, it's he's like...
Minus 20.
He's doing great.
Yeah.
Oh, I'm gonna get the gum rush so we can have seeds.
So we can plant.
But, God, there's so many just dead animals on the ground as
I'm walking.
They all, like, spawn next to us, which is great.
Get over here.
Wait, where is our base gonna be again?
Our base is gonna be...
Keep walking.
Do you see the tower in the distance?
You're gonna walk towards that, and then you're gonna, like,
turn left.
Okay.
I see it.
Get over here.
Oh my god, get the fuck over here.
There you go.
Everything will be fine.
Yay!
Fight.
Where's the are you guys do you guys have another bench down
there or no, um, you can just build and disassemble Oh, okay
Look at that.
That's mine.
You get all the stuff back.
Yeah, this is why you're on my team This is why you this is
why you matter.
This is why you you matter That's a way to put it I guess
You are an asset to this company See parents you were wrong
I'm not a disgrace being a 2d anime girl We have literally
been slaughtering everything I just saw one of the little
woolly guys and I was like oh I'm gonna fight him dead
literally dead that's the fourth one Nice should have killed
them faster Alright chicken There needs to be a 10 minute go
fight chicken Ryan great asset great great asset Go fight.
Nice.
Go, chicken, go.
I should have had the Lyft Monk right at the start.
That's fine.
My chicken's level seven now.
Well, that's right.
I only have worthless pals right now.
Where are the penguin pals?
Don't we need that for like...
Kind of near base, actually.
go oh is it the base uh are you already up there no oh wait
this isn't the base sorry i i got a little lost already all
right grab stuff nice free items yeah i'll try to get to the
base ahead of everybody else um my little chicken i like
being cucumbered my little chicken i like being cucumber i
don't know what i'm gonna name this chicken wait how do you
Name your pals.
Uh, in the menu.
In the menu?
F on them or something?
If you go to your party, you can name them.
Oh!
Okay.
I'll name you.
Oh, I name it.
Where the fuck is it?
I just go this way?
Can I just go this way?
Where the fuck are you naming?
Maybe I can just go this way.
Also, there's an egg.
Oh, yeah.
Pick up eggs.
I just picked up.
Yeah, I picked one up.
Oh, there it is.
That's the best way to get good pals without being in a
high-level area.
Okay.
Nice.
If you don't have space, just get rid of the small ones
before you get rid of the big ones.
Don't worry.
I have so much space right now.
Oh, my God.
There's so many dead pals here.
I wonder who did that.
Who did that?
That's crazy.
Holy shit.
I wonder who...
What the...
Everywhere I go, I see dead pals.
You know, like, the official, like, Power World YouTube
channel posted that short about, like, cooking lambels?
Yes!
I saw it.
I was like, ah!
What's so curious?
Like, the creator does, like, Pokemon versions, too.
Oh, my guys, watch the Pokemon versions are, like, more
fucked up.
Like, I love how, like, Power World people are like, yeah,
we want them to make something for us.
Yeah, me, me, me!
Nintendo, this is what we've been asking for.
All these years.
Nintendo would never...
We don't want to make normal sandwiches.
I want to make Pokemon sandwiches.
Oh, me too.
What would be the most tastiest Pokemon sandwich, though?
Oh.
Okay, what's the wag you of Pokemon?
Isn't there like a cow Pokemon?
Milk tank?
I don't think...
Yeah, Taurus, Taurus.
No, Taurus would be...
But he would be chewy.
He's got too much muscle.
Taurus?
I bet Ditto tastes like jam.
Oh, yeah.
I feel like legendary...
I can't agree to that.
I feel like legendary Pokemon would be like the most juicy
because they're like aged really well, too.
No, no, because like, you know how like the older they are,
the more aged they are.
It's about the marbling.
Yeah, yeah.
But wouldn't like legendary Pokemon have like really good
marbling if you think about it?
Since they're legendary.
You got to think about the one with the most like fat on it.
would be the most delicious one?
No, because then there's also slow poke.
Snorlax!
No, Snorlax!
Tail is good, right?
Oh, Snorlax!
He doesn't move!
I mean, he's like...
But then it's mostly fat, though.
He's so tasty.
But wouldn't it mostly be fat?
It's going to be hard to get lean meat from Snorlax.
Oh, yeah.
Maybe you can combine Pokemon.
You can use his fat to, like, fry another Pokemon.
Oh, Truid.
Like, use his fat to make bacon.
If you think about it.
Yeah.
What is the bacon of the bacon of Pokemon?
Uh, the little pig, the little fried pig.
He can fry himself, too, because he's firetight.
T-Pig?
Oh, T-Pig!
But they're hard to breed.
Yeah, you don't need to...
I mean...
They're, like, too rare to be the bacon of Pokemon.
What's, like...
Depends on whether you have Nintendo Online, because if you
have a Nintendo Online, then every time you go to the
mystery trade, all you're going to get is...
and no online someone says you free to play or pay to play
that's the question all right all right i'm placing our pill
box uh give me one second
okay i want to move my god just a little bit so i can get
the trees i'm gonna head over i need to get more no i think
this may be the best i'm gonna get maybe the best i'm gonna
get all right my chicken peas level nine now look at him go
no i think it should be further over where am i Is this me?
This is me.
I'm heading over to our base.
Okay, building it now.
You should be able to fast travel once I finish it in five
seconds.
Oh, oh yeah, fast travel.
I almost forgot.
I'm just gonna head to the...
Alright, it's set.
Alright, build a wooden chest and deploy a pal.
Okay, so I have a human.
Wait, you caught one already?
Nice!
Oh my god!
Nice, we just need 19 more.
We need to build our little- No, but four of them have to be
level 10.
Oh, but I guess we could par level them to be level 10.
Do we have to catch them- We need to build our little
prison.
Do we have to catch them at level 10, or do we have to par-
Like, do they just have to be level 10?
I don't remember.
You could just level them up, sure.
How are they gonna know?
Uh, watching our streams?
No, what's the point?
bullshit No way they watch this I did not consent to be
tracked I didn't accept the cookies Yeah we didn't consent
to be like moderated in a tournament What the fuck Are you
trying to tell me?
It's an invasion of my privacy Watching us right now that's
fucking illegal
Oh I should grab some iron I we're Base level 2.
Shady bed, primitive workbench.
Oh no, my weapon!
I have a damaged weapon.
Do we have a repair shop and the base?
I'm about to build it.
Not yet, though.
What do you mean by shop?
Someone just asked me how I get rid of being wanted without
dying.
I don't know, just don't even witness, man.
Just don't look.
It's that easy.
Close your eyes.
And tell me about how much you're wanted.
That's kind of cringe, bro.
uh stone and wood all right i need supplies rock and stone
if you can put if you can put supplies in the chest all
right here's some meat here's some wood some rope i'll put
the eggs here too the rope and you'll build a shoddy bed
which means that i need infrastructure oh a raid already
already being raided that's fast okay uh all right i put
some wooden foundation here Let's catch these guys.
Let's do it.
I don't have any.
Okay.
Here you go.
Let me make some balls right now.
Bals.
I need more wood.
If anybody has an abundance of wood, if you can bring back
the base, that'd be great.
I can bring some back.
In the meantime, let me assign some pals.
Oh, here they come.
Here they come.
Oh, shit.
Wait, they're not even...
They're really fucking cute.
They're not even the good ones.
Yeah, but they're cute, though.
They got the...
gamer hoodie they probably drink gamer subs it's probably
their entire blood all right all right let's let me get
ready to chill all right there you go nice oh they're not
even the humans what's the point yeah cut this trees for us
i already forgot what the achievements are i just just thank
you for the one most of the day one achievements are just
killing the field bosses pictures and so we just all power
level all right we are gonna be base level three I think you
have to only get to base level seven that's what the
screenshot said really okay I thought no it's 12 it's 12.
it's 12 though the screenshot showed seven well I got to I
got to seven in about an hour yesterday when I tested it oh
that's I think it's 12 because I think the screenshot is
just to show you guys and be like this is how you take a
screenshot If you guys didn't know what it looks like, this
is how the screenshot thing looks like.
I'm gonna...
I need the...
Okay, I'm gonna...
I need the repair bench.
Oh, I'm gonna get a...
They farm ore really well.
The piggies.
Shit.
Let's see...
Repair bench...
Are you making repair bench or am I making the repair bench?
I can make it just one second.
Okay, JK, I made it.
Okay.
That works too.
Here we go.
Nice.
Let me repair my fucking pickaxe.
Alright, I'll see.
Oh, wait, actually, I need to make clothes.
Because I'm still naked.
Oh, yeah, it isn't even nighttime.
And we're already at this point.
This is actually really good.
Making pretty good time.
I should not put this so close.
I forgot how finicky everything is.
Nah, burn it down.
It's all good.
down.
I mean, oh, I still need two cloths.
Do I make...
You should fast travel probably back to the start area.
That's the fastest way to get wool is to kill the lambs.
Yeah.
Until I can build a ranch.
Cloth.
No, it's cool.
I forgot you can make cloth with wool.
Nice.
Now I'm not making anymore.
Okay.
Yay Yay, it's almost nighttime.
I got my I got my clothes on I got my clothes on If you guys
can try to catch the the flying bat thing.
Yeah, we can use him for mining All right, the tombat the
tombat.
I have one mining pile.
I have like the rush boar Oh, the rush boar is good for now.
Yeah, rush boar is nice.
Yeah, you just put it in for now to mine the iron puts the
fire right next to the wood structure it's fine we're what's
gonna happen to us oh my god I can't see can't see oh yeah I
need to go fight chill it so I can get ancient point so I
can get us a gig incubator oh all right I need to be like
level 15 for that so I'll have to go level at some point
yeah go power or or or somebody with a high level who
unlocks it can just build it Sure for what's your level?
I'm level level You're level level?
You're level level?
I'm level level.
Are you in range to fight chill it yet?
I need fucking like arrows and shit for that motherfucker.
You don't need arrows.
You can one man it.
Yeah, I bet you.
You're a gamer.
Yeah.
Well, yeah, I'm gonna one man it of course.
Yeah, but are you trying to say you're not good enough to...
good enough to do it without i said i'm working on what are
you working on what are you working on right now i'm working
on making nails so i can send them to a merchant so i can
get millions of dollars so then i can buy arrows so i don't
have to craft them why don't you just craft it because it
takes two years but we but we have the ingot or you don't
have to make you don't have to make like the or is going to
be easy getting ingot is going to be easy because of our
base location Exactly.
Yeah.
Just skip arrows.
Just go straight to gun.
Yeah.
Okay.
You want to give me a freaking gun then?
Oh shit, I forgot to make clothes.
Just get one forehead.
Yeah.
From where?
Just buy it.
We're not in America.
If we're not in America, how do all these other people get
guns?
All right.
Tell me where the closest fucking Walmart is.
I'll get a fucking pump.
You live in Central.
You know where the closest Walmart is.
I transfer that into Palworld.
Turn your webcam on.
While you go to Walmart.
There you go.
Easy.
I forgot we all have to catch some to get the...
What was it?
The extra points.
The registered points.
I think you can just drop...
Like, give Pal...
Pal's to other people.
Oh my god!
Yeah, that's so smart!
You can't just put them in the base.
Yeah, and then we just pick it up and grab it as registered.
that's actually so smart yeah i don't have a tombad yet but
i have boar in box i'm gonna put i have duck yes take one
from the base that'll register in your thing but it doesn't
register as a first catch so you can still get the bonus exp
i'm only leveling stamina and carry weights all right i put
a i put a i can do you need a penguin i have penguin and a
duck Yeah, I got a fuck.
Oh, fuck.
Oh, he finished the cloth.
I got a new stat.
It finishes, but cannot acquire.
I'll put it in.
All right.
I need to make myself an outfit.
My motherfucker's gone bad.
I can't see.
It's so dark.
Yeah, I got the...
If you have the fire pal, it's really useful.
Oh, shit.
You're right.
Yeah.
You're so smart.
He lights up.
You gotta make a torch.
Dude, sometimes my brain cell has to corner and fall.
You just have your one big breakthrough.
I do shit myself in the process, but it's okay.
Awkward silence.
Ruminating.
It's so cute.
You matter.
Don't worry, Lily.
Silence can be a beautiful thing.
Yeah, maybe I should just shut the fuck up sometimes.
Who knows?
Oh, wait, the presser can also mine.
I don't, I can't find tombads yet, but...
Okay, that's fine.
We'll find it eventually.
I'll just like invest a thing for now.
Oh, also, if you, if somebody can get an elk like that, uh,
blue and purple, like, shiny elk looking thing, that thing
helps with, uh, with wood.
All right.
We're not at that point yet, though.
No rush.
I'm just gonna...
Let's see.
Why do I want to go back to base?
I don't even remember why I'm here.
Where are you?
I'm at the base.
Whoever.
I'm going to go back to base.
I am bringing depressor.
He's dead though.
So I have to put him in the box.
Oh yeah, I wanted to build more balls.
Okay.
Balls time.
I mean, we're making good progress.
Yeah, we're doing good.
I think.
Surely we are.
30 minutes in so we're doing good oh my god look at us go
like we gotta be doing like all right yeah right we can't be
last right right i think we're i think we're base five now
is there achievements for the towers yeah there is there is
let me look at the achievement list five achievement report
where the is the achievement link oh there where okay you're
supposed to be telling a mod to look at it for you so they
can respond to chat while you're doing things in the game
you know anything about multitasking you know anything about
multitasking okay faction tower yeah 20 points per team um
and then like one is 20 two is 60 three is 150 four is 250
um and five is 350 palladium fragment if anybody's got one i
got one okay okay let's see i'm in base also box you must
defeat a boss we're all i'm hitting rocks using fox sparks
with a weapon last hit with spot sparks using a unique skill
oh we have to do a thing where we all have spot sparks all
right i'm gonna be about a global event or a day one event
it's a global yeah so we can do that like on day two yeah uh
we had to catch five lambbell at the same time using traps
how the fuck i guess we all just i don't know someone that
knows how traps works when do we unlock traps what level is
that we already unlocked it i'm pretty sure okay yeah then i
guess we have to build that at the starting area oh
everything is you pathetic fox work harder yeah tell him
yeah tell him build that dictatorship to podium
grab some more palladium fragments or more balls later i
need 20 palladium fragments to do the next two things I got.
Oh, okay, I can grab some now.
Just put 40 in the box.
We need 11.
Oh, okay, cool, then we're good.
We're good then.
Oh, wait, let me repair my ship.
Nice.
I don't see any Tombat anywhere.
I saw a daydream.
It spawns near the second waypoint near the Mammal Forest.
Oh, okay.
Alright, I guess I'll go back then.
Oh, no, no, it's day time now.
Back.
Oh, yeah, rip.
Daytime.
We have a repair bench?
Yeah, it's at base.
Am I blind?
Maybe.
I guess so.
What the fuck?
It's okay.
We all have one blind spot.
I don't.
I am.
Oh yeah, sorry, you're perfect.
I'm perfect.
I can't fucking see.
I'm pretty sure your chat can figure out something that
you're not perfect.
Oh yeah, for sure.
They're going to say everything.
Yeah, do you think your chat's lying?
Yes.
I would say your chat's lying.
They only want to see me in pain.
And you're not cultivating a good chat.
It's not like a YouTuber chat where everyone's super nice
and will die for you.
Is that true, chat?
Is that true?
What kind of chat did you cultivate?
I cultivated a base chat who's not afraid to say their
opinion.
No.
Wait, then their opinion is true then.
Unless you guys...
Opinions can be wrong.
That's what they are.
Their opinions.
Not all, but are you trying to say every opinion you chat
has is wrong then?
No, I'm saying every opinion is an opinion, dokeybird.
Yeah, yeah.
So are you trying, so then...
Do you know what an opinion is, dokeybird?
Yeah, but then it could be right or wrong.
So you're trying to say that their opinion is wrong.
If it doesn't agree with me, then I permabill.
abandon so you're censoring them yeah whoa that's a
dictatorship out here that is a pal world gamer right there
the truth will eventually come out what truth sure for
chatters you come here to say your truth say your truth here
this is a safe space from sure for my place is a safe space
people rarely it's just the option is there that's the auto
mod i didn't do that you have to establish dominance every
now and then so when my chat was like he was mean to me good
run oh there's the city here's the town get over here life
monk oh my god he's running so fast okay get over here uh
stone pit logging site yes we're finally at the stone pit
and logging site all right cool yay i need better am i high
enough pokemon that's a that's a question please where are
they box park please shoot him i don't want to chase this
lift mug for like 20 years please
do you think i can put the logging site on on top of a tree,
or is that an exploit?
Cool.
Yeah, you can try it out.
You can try it out.
Ask for forgiveness, not permission.
That usually goes.
I never told us, Natsu.
Oh, sick rocks.
That's true.
Please, I've been trying to kill this Lyft Monk for like
five minutes now.
He's always running.
Look at this, I'm too lazy.
Yay.
Okay, we need to be level 24 somebody needs to be level 24
for us to get base level 12 That's the last recipe is at
level 24 I'm working on it 24.
Okay, I'm working on it.
What level are you right now at once we get to that point?
All we need to do is do material management to get it to
level 12.
All right But we probably need to catch more stuff I'm
working on it What level are you right now?
13 we're almost there i'm 10 i think close close i'm 13 11
sorry i'm 11 too yeah let's go let's go we're doing our part
it took me like five minutes to catch one lift mug but i'm
doing my part we're getting it okay let me build a ranch
because then we don't have to make pow balls anymore yay but
how much do those actually make the balls when it's split
between four not great but I can make two ranches if I get
enough wood and stone ram ranch what do we need the most
right now right now we need both wood and stone okay I'll
just do wood right now stone.
I might as well just cut some wood.
Pit tree.
Punch tree.
Do any of my boards do?
Okay, we're a cart.
What do you do?
You do mining.
Mining away.
I don't know what's left to mine.
I mine in any ways.
Oh my god, I can do Minecraft plot covers now.
We only need to be level 20.
Oh, nice.
Fuck these trees.
I'm gonna go level up a little bit.
Oh shit, I'm two.
I'm slowly walking over.
Mine diamonds.
Don't worry.
I'm worrying.
I'll be the lumberjack of this team.
I just really enjoy walking around, punching pals.
Wait, did you not make a weapon?
I just have a weapon.
Oh, your fist.
Yeah.
My fist is made out of steel.
Arcus are surprisingly very strong.
What the heck?
Why are my fists too slow?
I just want to beat up this green squirrel.
Yeah, that was me too.
I gave up halfway.
I'm sorry, the back bonus is surprisingly effective, so.
You're going to bane him?
What?
You're going to bane the squirrel?
Yeah, I bane him.
Damn, that's fucked up.
I'd do it to him.
Why were they running?
So they won't die?
What the fuck?
They just die in snow and that's kind of judgmental.
I mean, they don't know anything about me.
I can be really nice.
You're trying to beat up a squirrel.
Does that sound like a nice person here?
You are not the nicest person here.
some dudes down here maybe my hands just want to talk man
i'm gonna catch these guys i'm mining i'm mining all right
guys how many people do we already have what do you mean we
have one people we have one oh yeah we're gonna see people
hopefully we're about to have more people yeah i will catch
people too yeah all right we got another person we got
another one for Yeah, I'm going to catch another one right
now.
We're doing our part, Lily.
You're like a little set up.
I don't get a gun.
People catching.
Woo.
This is what we wanted, Nintendo.
This is what we wanted.
I want a cash Professor Oak.
Yeah, but Nintendo will never do anything because they're
too big.
They make...
I feel like Nintendo's main revenue is just merchandising at
this point.
It's not even gained.
I got the police is after me.
It's okay.
Let me just get this person.
I just want this person.
I punched him into a rock and now I can't get him anymore.
And I can't.
I need to shoot him.
Kill him.
What do I do?
Make a message.
What the fuck?
Well, there goes my only pal ball.
Anyway, there's a guy down here in the rock.
If anybody has a pal ball and want to catch him, he's like
right here.
Wait, where is he?
Right down this hill.
I'm out of...
Okay, I have pal balls.
I'm out of balls.
I can almost make a crossbow.
I got him out of the rock, though.
And he's ready to catch.
Okay, I'm trying to fight.
Oh, I see you.
I'm heading over.
Don't worry.
Help me.
I'm coming over.
Five nails.
My knight in shining armor.
Where are you?
I'm coming over.
Don't worry.
I went the wrong way.
I'm coming over for real now.
Is he still there?
Yeah, he's still shooting at me.
Oh, boy.
Just live.
Help.
Don't worry.
Wait, where in the world are you?
Should I go the wrong way?
I don't even see your name on the map anymore.
Don't worry.
I'm going the right way for real this time.
Oh, okay.
I see.
Oh, fuck.
I think.
I'm here.
Don't worry.
Yeah, you're coming.
You're coming.
Help me.
I'm right here.
Hello.
I feel like Boar's gonna fucking kill him before I catch
him.
Okay.
All right, you have to hit him in the head because he
doesn't technically have a hitbox.
There you go.
Oh my god, look at this one pistol.
You should be able to get him, though.
Yeah, I got him.
No!
Oh, I got him out.
I got him out, though.
Come on, get over here.
I have five more.
Oh, wait, that's your Boar.
That's my Boar, yeah.
I have five more.
I was trying to kill it.
He's six?
Oh, I got it!
We got a syndicate thug.
I'm gonna put some dudes in here.
Alright.
We're doing it.
Alright, I'm gonna put my human in the pal box.
Wait, he's already in here.
I'm being assaulted by three officers for assaulting a
person.
Oh, shit.
That's it.
It's like assaulting people is a bad thing, Lily.
I hope
No big deal and they but they already have a home.
What do you mean?
But I can't make a homie your home, but their family isn't
their original home Are you trying to see your buddy now?
This hole was made for me
Wow, don't talk to...
Never mind.
I'm not going to make that show.
Go on.
No, no, no, no.
No, say it with your chest.
No, no, it's okay.
It's okay.
Say it with your chest.
Don't go for European, Lily!
Don't go for European!
You're so European!
Well, you were going to go that route, huh?
Wait, what happened on the rock?
Never mind, never mind.
This is ending to a tribals!
We can't get away with this!
Alright, do now do we have enough for the stone pit?
Alright, I'm putting out the stone pit.
Alright, nice.
I should have built the ranch first.
Wait, what do I need for the ranch?
Don't worry, it's a good option at this point.
Alright, don't worry, I have a lot of stone.
I'm coming over.
Maybe just put it in the box.
Yeah, I'm going to put it in the box.
You got any fire Pokemon in the paldex?
We've got one.
I got only the Fox Sparks.
What the?
I put the stone in.
Rock and stone.
Okay.
Do we need more stone?
No, I think we're good.
I'm going to build the first branch.
Nice.
I know it's a make a newbis.
It's like that green panda and uh the female bee oh no
that's how you breed female bee female bee the the the
vespah queen but like pow world but the pow world version of
it
oh no not fucking pickaxe i like seeing the little syndicate
guy also swinging hammer here It's actually kind of
endearing.
He's doing his part.
Our little teammate.
He's a great asset.
Great ass.
Great, great ass.
What the hell name is that?
It says, are you guys making a crossbow?
Oh, you're making a crossbow.
I'm making a crossbow.
Oh, nice.
Oh, where's the repair bench?
And I'm going to go murder things.
Oh, I think I put...
Wait, did I...
Did I just assemble the repair?
Why is there, like, four benches?
We have, like, four benches.
We can be...
So we can work on multiple projects.
We have five.
Okay, I should know.
We should make we should replace them with the high quality
benches when we can though, because they make stuff faster.
High quality right here.
I'm gonna put a repair bench right here.
Now we have I don't know if we do have a repair bench, but
here is one too.
Nice.
Why is she so tanky?
I'm gonna go I'm gonna go catch some pals.
All right, let me put Oh, oh, where's Vixie?
It's the first mounted, pal.
Dyerwolf is pretty good.
Dyerwolf, oh, yeah.
You have to, like, chill it anyway, so you can just do chill
it if you want.
I'm going to try to find it.
The first one is.
I think it's Rushboard.
Yeah, the Rushboard is the first one.
I'm trying to remember where the Dyerwolf was.
How did it get the Dyerwolf?
It's near the bridge.
The bridge.
There's, like, a bridge near a waypoint.
Where is Dyerwolf?
it's not a google is not an exploit it's not all i'm gonna
say google is not an exploit all right so let's find which
what who fuck is that i don't know that's the word i've been
saying for a long time it's like a forgotten memory
let's see wait why can't i use this okay there we go don't
want to fly okay it is in the abandoned mineshaft okay where
am i first off where am i though
okay this is no i shouldn't make the max oh oh i think this
is the way i only made three arrows Yeah.
Wait, how many balls do I have?
I did not double check that.
Yeah, you always gotta check your balls before you go out.
No comment.
I want you to live with that thing you just said.
I want you to think about what you just said.
Man, I think he's not really my strong suit.
It's all good.
I don't agree.
Dang.
You gotta check your boss and make sure you don't have
cancer.
No, that's for breasts, right?
No, no, I think you can get testicular cancer.
Yeah, yeah, you have to do that for, yeah, testicular cancer
too.
Mm-hmm.
Yeah.
Okay, you check for lumps.
So you would say you have fondled them.
Sure, boy, did you check your...
Yeah, Chad, you should fondle...
Chad, make sure you don't have lumps.
Real quick, real quick.
Stop telling your VTuber chats to fondle their balls.
You know, half of them have lived for a statement like that.
Trevor, did you check your balls today to see?
Yeah, did you?
I'm being harassed right now.
We're not the ones checking.
We're asking if you checked yourself.
Yeah.
It's one of the global achievements, I think.
I'm not going to talk about my balls.
We're just concerned about your health.
Cap.
Wow.
We're just here trying to be a good friend, making sure you
don't have to stick to your cancer listen reverse the rules
all right all the women chat have you guys checked your
breast to make sure you don't have breast cancer just make
sure we want you to be safe give a little swipe of the
mammaries all right pressure's built i think that means
we're going to the next uh base level all right nice seven
all right hot spring oh shit i'm i know my balls don't worry
my chickpeas here i'm not worried anymore no my little
chicken it's okay i need a wooden stone but we need to
assign people to the like actual mine right now we have like
this shitty little green chipmunk doing all of the all of
the wood what do we need for it oh we need a tombad we need
that blue and purple blue and purple uh elk guy elk whatever
his name is and we But if we can't get a combat, that's
fine, but...
We just need to wait till nighttime right now.
Yeah.
It's not nighttime, so we can't do anything.
But the elk would be good.
Elk should be out right now, so...
If you see one.
Still trying to figure out where the dire wolf is.
They're on me.
They're on you?
Where are you?
Oh my god, you're so far away.
I'm heading over.
I think I need to go...
Level.
Whoa!
Not the poor sheep!
It's taking so long!
I want to build the second ranch.
Wait, maybe I can catch this person.
Oh, I should get a glider.
Oh, wait, I got another human!
We have three humans now!
Nice!
More human.
Let's go.
More work.
Something you're doing?
What are you sure for?
All right.
Soak, soak.
work
Oh, I know where the wait, oh, there's a shiny lambel No,
get it don't get it don't kill it.
Don't kill it.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, we do tiebreaker is
shinies, I think no we get extra points as well All right,
uh Ah, so much more damage Please shikabeen do not kill him
Make it so Make it so they're non-aggressive.
Hold four.
It's fine, we're fine.
It's okay.
I'm beating him up right now.
I'm beating him up now.
Whoa.
I'm gonna make sure I don't accidentally kill him myself.
I think it's faster to die and just try again.
What the fuck?
Oh, I got it!
I got shiny!
Clip it!
GG!
Yo, chat, go do it.
Flip it, bro.
Guys, I haven't been on this Twitch in a long time.
Do I even have Vaughn history on?
I actually did it, chat.
Oh, no.
That's against the rules.
I have an excuse.
I have an excuse, though.
You have no excuse.
I have this note from my doctor.
I do.
It's okay.
I might die, though.
I do, though.
I do.
It's fine.
So close!
I'm just saying this.
Saves!
Has anybody gone to the Chile yet?
Oh wait, I have no, clips are not on.
Wait, let me put clips on.
Guys, remember to go back to my VOD and clip it when I put
it back on!
Wait, no, if it's...
Wait, if you don't have it on, you won't have a VOD.
Oh wait, clips are on!
Don't worry, people were...
Yeah, people were fucking around.
It's okay, clips are on.
Wait, do you guys see?
Okay, there's an outpost over here with the thugs.
They've got those elks over there.
Oh, okay.
Nice.
Why are so many dire wolves here?
Yeah, we should probably go get those elks.
I have no health because I have no food.
But...
Maybe I'll find some food.
If I die, that's probably better, so that's fine.
If I die, I die.
You die, just respawn forehead.
Oh, wait.
Did I just die?
maybe
nice I got direwolf what am I dead?
What level is direwolf mount?
Oh I think I died.
Alright, I'm gonna give up any second.
Oh wait I like, I fell into the water and for some reason oh
I must have taken fall damage!
Oh okay wait what level is the direwolf mount?
I don't remember.
15?
Well something oh okay I have enough.
It's pretty early thing see where is it oh there it is okay
nine yeah i can afford it now oh no please don't kill me elk
spotted getting help yeah nice thank you nice there's like a
couple of that outposts i want to kill me god he's so fast
hit him enough so so he'll so he'll hit back come here boy
as long as you don't hit first you didn't start the fight
you can finish it though yes there's a oh nice there's my
stuff oh I see you sure for I'll show hey oh I'm catching it
that'd be spam catching I'm trying I'm trying man where the
fuck is the Oh my god, I'm fucking dying.
Holy shit.
How do I get over there?
We got the elk.
Oh wait, I've got my glider now.
I need to get home.
I'm so fucked right now.
I have 99 HP.
Alright.
Back to the base I go.
Deploying elk in base.
I'll be there soon.
Alright.
Putting all my resources.
Oh I'm gonna drown again.
Why am I like this?
Our pals are our pals They're stressed out.
Oh, no, they're so depressed.
Oh, no.
Someone do something I'm gonna drown again.
Okay.
I need Leatherwood fiber.
Oh, I think I should have enough for a mount Where the fuck
is the there it is.
Why why have I tried this twice?
That's just I have a low of 14 chicken.
Nice.
Help me, handyman.
It's about hit nighttime, too, so we can try to get a...
Oh, yeah, it's on bad again.
Yeah, it's on bad again.
Fuck.
Yay.
Nice.
Quiet.
Oh, yeah.
Let's see.
I wanted more balls.
Elk has been deployed.
Nice.
There's arrows being crafted somewhere If anyone wants to Do
a better weapon as well Do a little leveling
Need more balls What do I need?
Let's see Where am I missing wood?
Okay When do I get it?
I can't see Fox!
Give me the light!
I'm like ADing out of habit like fpse AD AD AD AD AD AD AD I
can't stand still when I'm Yeah, I can't stand still while
I'm fucking chopping a tree What does AD stand for?
A and D Really?
What do the letters AD stand for?
Oh yeah Because it's fort that's why because like in
Fortnite I yeah yeah give me credit yeah no don't i
literally see all right it's night time you're a fortnighter
bro i spend like at least 500 on fortnight skins and i'm not
proud of it man fortnight's really fun though it's near the
combat should be near the mammoth swine right yes okay i'll
see if i can find them yeah mammoth swine forest oh i see i
found the Let's go!
Get over here.
Get your ass over here.
Great progression.
Get over here.
I'm gonna fucking catch you.
Whoa.
It's self-defense because he shot first.
Yeah, tell your lawyer.
You saw a chat.
He shot first, guys.
Oh my god, I actually might die.
I'm fucking around way too much.
Get anything for these diaries?
Oh no, oh no.
I don't think so.
is the limelock achievement is that a global one or is that
just a day one it's a global i'm pretty sure yeah yeah it's
a global cool cool all that day one achievements are like
very uh just mostly catching the bosses um except for the
bases and the
I had two Tombats.
Who do we replace then for the Tombats?
Well, we actually, we should be able to build the next
thing.
Sorry, I'm not at base right now, but we should be able to
build the next thing now, which I think is another berry
thing.
We were out of resources last time, but we should be able to
do a base upgrade, and then you can just throw them in.
All right, what do we need for the berry?
Give me one second.
I'm almost back at base.
Okay, I got the Tombat.
I'm heading over to the base.
Alright, sounds good.
10-4.
I'm getting some Wock.
Wock.
Shruck.
Metal.
Seeds and wood.
We have a lot of seeds, so I think that should be fine.
I'm back in.
Seed fiber and wood.
Give me the light.
Let me just double check and see what we need.
Next base upgrade, we need one more barrel.
plantation and hot springs okay i got you a lot i can build
the hot springs right now
yeah i can put some wood for you thank you
and then all right yeah we have like 268 wood oh i have like
ancient civilization parts i have six how do i get six i
think we're gonna need that for the next upgrade What the
fuck did I grab have six already?
We don't need scope roads, do we?
What did I do?
We need five stone.
Oh, five stone?
Easy.
Yeah, I'll grab.
No.
Don't need it.
All right.
Oh!
When I caught the shiny lamb bill, I got ancient
civilization parts.
That makes sense.
I didn't notice that.
All right.
I put the five stone in.
We can do a dungeon run, too.
There's a dungeon right by the entrance our base we need the
do the dungeon bosses count towards anything uh no well
doing the dungeon towns in there uh we need to do the ravine
grotto dungeon and then the mountain stream grotto dungeon
as a team by the way okay so if you find the ravine grotto
dungeon that's what we have to do okay i'm not sure where
that one is but all right hey google where's the ravine
grotto dungeon It's not an X1 if it's on the internet.
Base level 8.
It is.
Wait, it's near us.
Base 8.
We need a medieval workbench and then we'll be base 9.
Okay.
What do we need for the medieval workbench?
Good question.
Okay, I'll put the tombats in.
Wait.
Alright, who do we replace for the tombats?
Anybody, really.
Anybody?
Okay, I'm replacing it.
Except for the elk.
anybody else is on there's no elk in here uh is someone
level 12 on base i'm not level 12 yet can you build the
medieval workbench yeah huh thank you i love myself all
right i got rid of the vixie and the creamy do we need those
okay no um vixie is probably is good to have uh creamy is
not all right i'll what do you want to replace for the vixie
then why'd they call it creamy do we need we don't need a
chicken can give us food we can get rid of the syndicate
thug we don't really need him all right we don't need him he
is a person you can't just throw people away you can't just
throw people away they all matter don't worry i'll go to the
black marketeer i'll sell them off dude i wish that we could
capture him but that's an exploit it's it's fun having him
on base no you can capture him you can get we can capture
him but we just can't capture him with a campfire yeah we
can't like as long as you're doing the damage and stuff yeah
i guess so all right i have the tombad in our pals are
stressed though because there's not enough beds uh okay i'll
build some more beds we're gonna find him someone's like
we're gonna find him a new family we'll take care of a much
better than any other family ever could true yeah exactly so
true all right i'm gonna say we could find that we have like
we have like three stars on yelp as a family oh the ravine
dungeon is like it's not bad it's not bad it looks like
we're trying our best sure but like we're not we're not
asking for perfection nobody's perfect you oh okay because
he's perfect he's the only perfect person out here well then
because he silenced all the other opinions no i'm not a
silencer oh we got two vixies then you literally say you ban
anyone whose opinions don't match yours putting words into
my mouth you can't silence you can't ban me you're too smart
to be gaslit
vixies in the ranch they're gonna make powballs for us nice
wait before i go how many people do we have at 12 i might
want to grab some more before i go okay did someone free
this all right we're base level nine nice there's nobody in
here i'm gonna have to start leveling up myself i can't
build any of the new things anymore um i can what do you
need built okay we need the sphere workbench which is level
14, and we need the cooler box which is level 13.
For those.
Dear Bansh.
Alright, let me see what materials we need.
And the cooling box?
The cooler?
We actually have enough stuff for it already.
We just need, uh... Oh, we need ice organs.
If anybody has ice organs.
Okay.
We know where to get them if we don't already have them.
Wait, who do we kill for that?
I'm gonna go get some real quick.
The penguins.
Oh, okay.
But they're nearby.
I'm gonna go murder them.
Yeah, I should be lots of penguins here okay i just murdered
you can put any ice organs you have in the in the chest we
can make the cooler all right oh i have 15 ice organs hold
up let me put a four back yeah there's three of you then
there's like five of them again it's so weird it's like what
are the achievements and i'm like well i can't share i don't
know why you can't share it i don't know i'm pretty sure
There is there is there's a viewer one.
They just didn't want to link the main one so it doesn't
crash and people edit it and we're just like what's going
on?
I'm freaking out Well if my mods have access that want to
share it, please do but I linked it once but I don't know if
my mods Did anything.
I don't know.
You know what just just enjoy like just enjoy the moment
Yeah, it's like you see I was catching humans.
You're like why are they wasting time catching a human?
What the fuck like that was a really nice way of saying I
don't want to do it.
Just enjoy the moment.
Don't get absorbed with this.
Like you're taking this too seriously.
Come on.
Yeah, just look at us.
Does it look like we're taking this so seriously?
I'm just gonna go drown myself.
Enjoy the moment.
And he's enjoying the moment drowning himself.
I'm gonna grab a couple things.
i'm gonna go level myself for a little bit and come back but
yeah cooler box and uh the other make another chest okay
cool cool cool put the put my ancient civilization thing and
then our first sphere works bench i can probably yeah i'm
gonna put it down in a second dude okay if i fail well you
said you already have 15 of those ice organs we have like 30
in there now by the way the boss penguin like the the one
for the achievement oh yeah yeah yeah we have pretty We have
30 already in there the other little guys that come with him
Wait, is the boss dungeon solo or can you do it in you have
to do as a team the oh wait actually the boss dungeons Let
me double check the four.
I can wait.
You can just solo catch them.
Um, yeah the boss dungeons.
Yeah, you can it's solo Oh, okay, uh, there's like other
stuff that's like Uh different That's like global for like
but we can easily do like other dungeons again Also, sure do
you do you already have the um incubator unlocked did you
fight a boss yet not yet okay okay i can make a breeding
farm okay i mean yeah what do we need right now right now we
need to build the i just need i just need someone who's a
higher level to build a thing what what level ow cooler
cooler box and sphere workbench 14.
14 oh i'm 14 already yeah oh i'm only 12.
I'm doing it.
Oh, you're doing it.
You're building okay.
We should have yeah We should have nails and ingots already
in the box where I'm doing it I'm gonna help us get more
ingots set Okay, I'm on a good level Have another dog with
me?
How about All right What's the dog doing?
What's the dog doing?
Grab more more ingots.
Oh, she respawned the NPC.
I can catch her now.
Maybe oh nice nice We're almost there.
We're almost at 20.
She keeps alerting the authorities.
How dare her call the cops?
Right?
We're trying to give her a better home.
And I'm shooting her and I had a couple times so she's
catchable.
What the heck, man?
Yeah.
She should enjoy the moment.
She's being too hot on herself.
Just enjoy the moment.
We should let it happen.
Just get caught.
Like, come on.
Just get caught, man.
VTubers are murderers.
What?
No!
Us?
I'm trying to not murder her, but all the police shows up
and they murder her.
Yeah!
It's self-defense.
What the?
Alright.
Let's see.
I have a lot of ingots.
Do we need more ingots, sure, for?
No, you want it again.
enough we need hella ingots on god all right shoddy be
trifling she gotta be i put a lot of ores in the box damn it
stay in the box ball thing it's comfy trust trust this box
is so comfy i'm gonna yes i did it okay what if i just fire
away i'm kind of wanted but like what if i just walk off
oh come on stay in the ball stay in the ball stay in the
ball follows me after capturing a human um that is that is
unfortunate can't believe this is where our tax dollars go
to can't believe you're funding this yeah i can't but this
is why you shouldn't fake taxes who's fox pirate this is
mine i put it there just hit me in the face already please i
beg you i got you whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa Nice.
Now it's a lot faster.
Faster burning.
Where in the world?
Where's that lift monkey?
They're just staring at me!
Oh my goodness, Anthony!
Please!
Lily, you matter, Lily!
You matter!
Don't do it!
Oh my god, please, I beg one punch in the face and surely
I'm dead.
There we go!
I Yeah, I'm more ore for you Mining away Uh, but I can do a
Minecraft cover now Hey You can play giraffe town now I can
play giraffe town Oh, yeah It's the legendary adventure
About giraffe in the town Whoa Whoa, that little black spike
there holy shit please stop lacking my game guys i'm level
15 now oh my god you're level 23 that is our power leveler
right there that is our power leveler have you caught any of
the have you caught any of the boss pokemon yet i mean
powmons yeah i think we should probably work on getting like
the chill out so we can get the egg incubator yeah Go,
sheriff for...
We're egging, we need the egg.
Oh, should we still have three hours?
Yeah, but the eggs take so long though, so we might as well
get it now.
No, no, the server has it, so it's like two minutes.
Oh.
Well, for large eggs, it's an hour.
Yeah, that's what I'm saying.
Yeah, so I feel like we should grab some eggs now.
Like, get the egging career now in case we find a large egg.
Let's see.
I'll grab some more ore for this.
No, my weapon!
Tom, it's taking a break.
I don't think so.
No race.
Is this a competition?
There's no other race in tournaments?
I dare you.
But you matter.
Don't worry.
But you do matter.
But please don't take a break, ever.
Peace and love.
Oh, I'm egging over there.
Oh, it's so far away.
I'll grab the chillit.
Where is it?
Chillit.
Chillit is, like...
it's okay i googled okay i do not know how to describe where
it is it's near us though it's not far
all right it's like here report my achievements what
achievement did i get it's okay pp's mod you got a shiny did
that count for yeah we got a shiny but which one what do we
report.
I don't know what's going on.
Peepie's mod, report my shiny lamp bell.
Go, Peepie.
Go.
Alright, nice.
Wait, do I have balls?
I do, right?
I don't.
Fuck.
I was there and I was like, wait a minute.
I don't even have my pal balls.
They were there in the next second.
That's what I said.
Before you leave, you gotta check your balls.
Always check your balls, guys.
Always check your balls before you leave.
Why is it always about balls?
It's okay.
I got one ball.
That should be enough for Chilin.
Mod says it's done.
Nice.
Sure, any balls matter.
Mod, make sure...
Okay, the cooler box and the PAL sphere is made.
Come on, make sure all our achievements getting reported.
Mots!
Unpaid interns, do your job.
We're not gonna...
We're not gonna write your references if you don't.
Nope.
That's right.
You'll never be able to leave me for a better streamer.
Exactly.
You'll never know.
Where the hell is this thing going?
Can't leave me if you don't have a resume.
Resume.
Alright, here you go.
Oh, King Paca?
Wait, what level is...
Oh, no, he's level 23.
No, fuck that.
Yeah, sure.
He's a big junker.
He's enough level for sure, for he's level 23 right now.
Yeah, fuck him up.
Yeah, fuck him up, sure for.
Do your power level thing.
I'm doing it.
Oh, hey, there's a Tifa in here.
I'm going to kill him.
All right.
I'm just going to level.
Where is Chillit?
Oh, perfect.
Oh.
All right, do your thing, Dyer Wolf.
Don't worry, I have my pickaxe.
Ow.
Don't worry, I'm doing, like, two damage per second with my
pickaxe.
Ow.
What?
Wait, the bonus AXP for, like, getting...
I got you!
It's only, like, 51?
What the fuck?
That's so little?
I've got the chillin guys!
Record it!
Let's bring it!
We can get the incubator!
Go to my stream right now!
Go peepees!
Go peepees go!
We got noodle.
I need butter piles.
I can't kill shit anymore.
My pile is just like...
Mining a rock while I'm fighting stuff.
Stop killing everything.
We're trying to catch them.
I'm heading over now to give us the incubator.
What the fuck?
The King Paca just ran off in the other direction.
Can you leave the boss area?
I think they all can technically if you aggro it.
If you aggro it, yeah.
I didn't aggro him, but dude, he's got shit to do, I guess.
I guess he forgot to pay his taxes or something.
He was in a hurry.
All right, let's see.
Uh...
Got to chill in right here.
I'm going to put that chill in my team now.
All right.
Let me level up that incubator.
We have...
We need palladium fragments.
Does anyone have extra palladium fragments?
Oh, I can mine some.
Yeah, I need some fragments to make the incubator.
Pretty sure I just put some in a chest.
Cut in a month.
Can't make it.
Oh, yeah, I did.
Yeah, yeah, I see it.
Alright.
Nice.
Alright, incubator.
I'm gonna put it right here.
Alright.
Here you go.
Right, right.
I should finally make a crossbow.
I've been trying to beat everything up with a pickaxe.
It wasn't really the smartest thing to do.
let's see it's so annoying I can't climb anything because of
like the pingy shield I guess every time I climb I have to
like slow climb because the second I press space I just like
snap back snap back to reality oh there goes gravity he's so
mad he won't give up that easy let's see get more weight in
here oh no my pals are stressed Get used to it This is your
life now Whoa We are We have a healthy work environment
Don't worry guys Nobody is getting abused I swear
Everybody wants to work for our company Our company Vegeta
and Piccolo hate the government Yeah yeah Money isn't real
tell them Money isn't real tell them Yeah
Let's see.
Ooh, I'm gonna grab more penguins.
Whoops.
Yo, my balls.
Alright, I should be 15 in a second.
Oh, I can't climb.
Wait, what's our PAL base?
Why do I have all those ingots?
What's our PAL base level right now?
Uh, it should be level 9 or 10.
Oh, shit, Rob was at 12.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, we're doing really good.
This.
I got the penguin.
It's only about materials now.
because we already have somebody the right level.
Good question.
I'm about to come back to base.
Yeah, I guess I can mine some materials right now for us and
then sure if we can make it.
I know that we're going to need Inget, but I have like 26.
I'm going to grab this.
Did we already build the cooler?
Yeah, we have a cooler.
Okay, okay.
Yeah, I already leveled the stage.
All right, I'm heading back.
When you talked it didn't work, I can just spam The dodge
button Don't try to kill something Doesn't fucking work
Would I have to stick to killing easy stuff So when I get
hit, it doesn't matter Wait, where the fuck is the Oh no Is
it up there?
No, it was up there?
Like trying to figure out where the Fast travel is down here
I believe in you I believe in you the death i'm so lost
all right grabbing this did we make the incubator we needed
yeah we did it's up on the cliff cool cool cool i put it on
the cliff i'm heading back nice i did it i found this thing
i did it did you catch the sweepie yet or sweet get a
sweepie sure for see it uh i'm gonna go catch stuff in a bit
but i just asked my chat if they're gonna clip it when i
kill a boss and they're all spamming no
guys sure for shad don't you want us to win they're gonna
say no that's not the question you want to ask okay don't
you want shy lily to win they're gonna still actually they
might say yes yeah they might say yes or it's lily Guys,
think of it better.
Lily wants to win.
Please just feel sorry for me.
It'll make it work.
It's like 50-50.
We got no if and yeses for that.
Let's see.
What do I need to do?
I'm trying to remember.
Oh, someone said if Lily wins, Sherpa wins, guys.
So no.
Don't guys, don't worry.
We'll kick Sherpa out at the last second.
So then only Lily.
Well, the only hour win, don't worry about it.
Don't worry.
We'll sue you for discrimination.
Make sure you get disqualified last second.
Yeah, yeah, don't worry.
Disqualified for what?
We'll plan an exploit on your PC.
Yeah, yeah, we'll plan something.
Don't worry.
How am I being called a cheater again?
Oh, it's a re-entering theme.
Yeah, you don't know.
You don't know.
What the?
As coincidence?
Mmm...
Mm-hmm.
I don't know.
Doesn't seem much of a coincidence anymore.
It'll co-winky-dink.
Surely there's some truth to it.
Mm-hmm.
I'm getting more iron.
Do we just need ore?
I've got a bunch, but I took it with me for some reason.
Yeah, but like what materials do we need for all the other
stuff?
Ugh.
Hold on one second.
Bye.
I'm gonna mark my map.
So one of Pia's mods said they would clip and don't worry
and now my chat is gunning them down.
Run!
They're like, hide the evidence!
Hide the evidence!
Run!
The moat is Helper's massacre if you don't know.
You weren't built for a flesh tubers chat!
You weren't built for it!
soft vtuber chat you leave them alone oh no you showed
weakness you're now you should never show weakness yeah they
they bite around here yeah all right i'm putting the ingot
in the chest i'm gonna look at sweep up where we don't count
deaths here stop we don't count deaths sweep up i have zero
deaths me too i'm counting too All right, wheat plantation
mill cooking pot Where the fuck is the sweeper boss?
How do you have the resources I can build it?
I think we have right I can build the wheat plantation.
We need wheat seeds though.
I'm not sure where we get them You buy them from my ventor
Okay, oh, we can just buy it.
Yeah, I need wheat seeds and let's see what do we need for
the cooking pot Where's the hell?
Otherwise, I think we have everything for that.
It's a new town.
Did you kill tanking?
Oh, I need someone who's level 17 to make the cooking pot.
I can make, uh, wait, what level am I?
We have all the stuff already.
I'm level 17.
I can make it, yeah.
I'll buy the wheat seed right now.
Thank you.
So I'll make the cooking pot.
Wait, what was the person?
There you are.
Mr. Merchant, do you have the seeds?
No, that's the pal of the merchant.
Alright.
I'm just trying to retrieve my stuff.
Mr. Merchant, do you have the seeds?
Oh, I got wheat seeds.
Nice!
I'm dead.
What can I build right now?
Oh, my God!
What happened?
My Pokemon weren't on aggressive, and then they didn't
attack.
And then I got Swiftie one shot.
You fell off.
Oh, my God.
There you are.
The most ratio.
All right.
in one of the boxes.
So you can just make it.
And then I'll make the cooking pot.
Where is the...
I'll make the wheat plantation and then someone can make the
cooking pot, yeah.
Yeah, I can make it now.
All right, cool.
Nice.
I'll put it right.
I'll put it next to the incubator.
Oh, can you put the wheat seeds in the box?
Yeah, I did.
I just did.
Oh, shit.
Should be in one.
Two more.
Oh, we need two wheat seeds?
We need three of them.
Yeah, sorry.
Okay.
Sorry, my bad.
I'll go buy it.
Do I have enough money?
We need two more, right?
Okay, yeah, two more.
Okay, I'm gonna get out of here.
Goodbye.
Don't worry, here I am.
God, we have so much ingot.
I love the space.
I have just enough for two more wheat seeds.
I'm gonna go grab the...
I'm gonna go grab the leather I left behind.
Nice.
Alright, now I'm broke for the wheat.
It's for the wheat.
It's a good purchase.
Do it for the wheat.
I'm handing over.
Someone's slacking off.
We have to eat him now.
Oh yeah.
Well, we can make a machete.
It's to send a message.
No slacking off.
Slack off and get eaten.
We can replace you with another life monk.
But you matter.
Don't worry.
large egg right um we got the cooking pot and nice i have
the second i have two seeds now i put it in okay thank you
i'll build up you need two beds for guys they're stressed
out got it yeah we got any extra arrows around her uh i'll
put some in the box thank you i'm gonna go catch Sweepa!
Oh, sorry, I only had seven.
My bad.
Yeah, good enough.
Where the fuck is this sweep?
Okay.
Sweepa boss.
Where?
Sweepa.
Where are you?
You're so far!
Holy shit, I can get there.
Get ready to report this.
I'm ready to travel so fucking far for this one Sweepa boss.
Wait, actually, can I...
We need more wood.
No, okay.
Guys, balls check.
Balls check.
Balls still there.
No, no, no, no.
I can't see it, but I think I'm going the right way.
I almost died, because I always...
Turn on my glider before I hit the ground.
but i forgot about the pig oh no oh no i think i'm dead i
accidentally ran into water accidentally in water no oh
he'll be fine i can't i think he'll be fine we'll just keep
swimming all right uh once the wheat farm is finished then
we're gonna be level 10.
we'll be okay i don't know where
Wait do I have to catch the boss or kill it because
technically I wait I'm next to you have to you have to
capture field you have to capture it
Guys get to me I found the reincarnated guy And we can do
that Okay, we need level 20.
We need someone to make the work bench.
I'm sorry, the weapons work bench at level 20.
I can make that.
I'll make nails right now.
Guys, I don't know if I can find him again.
Oh, you got nails?
Okay.
Oh, I see, I see.
I'll start.
I'll work on the map.
Wait, we can mark him?
We?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
All we need is the weapons work bench.
We'll be level 11 base.
Okay.
I marked him.
I did it.
I found, all right.
Nearly drowning saved my life.
we need uh for day two do we need a different level of base
or is it like just um day two we need 20.
okay yeah and then we have to catch a two black marketeer
they'll up any pal the low 50.
oh you can't catch them that okay cool yeah we have to catch
you later just normal just normal yeah no i know but i
didn't know that i didn't i i still feel like it's a little
bit exploited to catch them but like yeah okay no they even
said it's fine you can do the pal recycling
it's so dark I can't see I might just have to get the fox
spark my
alright we don't need a second tombat do we no we're good
yeah I already have two tombatts here we might as well catch
stuff to just level up yeah yeah true true and you get to if
you find a level 29 chickpea sure for it go for it because
we still need a level 30 chickpea Whenever you come back to
base, if you can build the weapon.
I think you have to level it yourself.
I don't think there's ever just going to be a random one
unless it's like...
Unless you find shiny.
Yeah, that's what I was thinking.
Oh, we find a shiny.
Oh my god, where am I?
That was responsive!
Cool.
I'm trying to get to the sweeper.
But I can't even see.
Uh-oh.
Four of my...
Oh, there you are.
Uh...
Okay, we're still low on wood.
I mean, I should try and capture a flying pal.
That would be very helpful.
I think the...
the easiest and best one you can get at this level is
like...
I guess it's still the...
bird one.
I want to get that Why is it the dragon one?
Yeah, that one's way sicker, though.
If you can make it out to the desert.
I need to figure out how to get there.
What the?
I'm going to kill that sweeper, and then I'm going to get
it.
Yeah, Quivern.
Yeah, I think that's the one.
Oh, I can't touch.
Oops.
All right.
Acquired.
Am I close?
Am I close to the sweeper?
Where is he?
I already forgot where he is.
Where's who?
The sweeper.
Sweeper.
He's so far.
Did you get all the nails made?
Yep, everything's made.
All we need is just somebody to make it.
What do I need to make?
It's level 20, the weapons workbench.
I'm always lost.
Where the fuck do I put it?
And then we'll be level 12 and we'll have completed base for
today.
Yay!
And then I guess it's just like...
I guess we can like keep leveling the base.
Oh yeah, we can keep leveling it.
Yeah, for sure.
We level it to level 19.
Yeah.
So we can get it for levels.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
True, true, true, base, base.
As long as you just don't hit the level up button, it
doesn't count.
Yeah, yeah, we just get it to level 19 and we're fine.
Yeah.
Oh shit, don't worry, Deja, I'm gonna save you.
Oh shit.
Oh, he's dead.
Okay, that's...
Sucks.
Okay, I got 21 tile balls.
I need to bury the...
I need to catch some stuff.
What is this?
Oh, hey, there's...
Hey, there's another Tombat!
Hey, yo!
But we don't need it anyway, so I'm just gonna release him.
Yeah, but I mean, if you get the 10...
That's true.
I'm gonna go catch this thing.
Nice.
Oh, I'm...
Put my pal's presence up, his...
Get over here.
Get over here, dire wolf.
No, please, I don't want to die because I'm still using my
pick ass as a weapon.
No!
Oh.
Okay, I'm just gonna leave.
Get over here, dire wolf.
We're gonna leave.
Where am I?
Oh.
I should really start crafting a bow.
I want to get a crossbow.
Yeah, I need a crossbow too.
I have not been crafting.
I was scared to craft one.
I was like, oh shit, that's not an ingot cost.
I was like, ah!
What the hell is happening to this spark?
Alright.
See where am I?
Yay, it's almost daytime!
Hold up.
Oh, hey, there's a Toko-toko.
We needed those, right?
Oh, nice.
We need that.
Yeah, we need 10 of them.
Yeah, okay.
Yeah, now that we've almost got our base up to 12, we might
as well like go towards the desert, I think.
Yeah, there's one here on me.
Yeah, there's one.
Should we start doing the bosses that we have to do
together?
I don't think there's any bosses.
Yeah, there's no bosses.
We have to... Oh.
We... Just dungeons.
We have to do together, yeah.
them don't worry google where are they they're like level 19
dungeons
all right how many tokens do we need i forgot the thing 10 i
think okay i got one noise all right nice we just need get
over here over here don't blow up don't blow up though blow
up oh shit no please no did you explode i died no i wanted
to catch him guys i'm right no not like this man not like
this my first death and then if i will kill them first time
huh first time first time first time
one you'll get there
okay all right nice all right let's see where did i die oh
there it died i can't believe it the bird on bird violence
like here where the did i die dungeon did anybody take down
penking yet Nope.
Yeah.
So about that.
He sort of killed him.
Yeah.
It's like the, it's not that he's hard.
It's the other ones.
My dire wolf kind of killed him while I was waiting to
respawn.
Yeah.
Oop.
Just a little oopsie.
Yeah.
I mean, doesn't that count though?
I mean, apparently we have to catch them.
Oh, okay.
Should we start making, once you have the, well, we've
already got the Palsphere wrench we can already start making
gigaspheres or whatever the green ones are called all right
we can make hyperspheres i can at least i think you're at
the point that you can make hyperspheres yeah all right i
gotta go back and see oh there's a there's some more iron
see he can hear somewhere when do we unlock the secondary
location uh We might have already, actually.
I don't know what level that unlocks at.
The secondary base?
We'll check right now.
I'll go check.
Yeah, when will we be over to you reach that point?
Wait, where do we put our secondary base then?
Yeah, I think you unlock it at level 10.
Yeah, we have it.
We have it.
Okay, yeah.
Where do we want to put our second base, though?
I don't know.
You're the base expert.
That's probably near the desert or something.
Yeah, desert sounds nice.
Where's the fuck did I put my own repair bench?
There it is.
also make like uh gun stuff oh we're the oh that's not it oh
my god there's so many benches which is the bench i need oh
there's too many too much benching i need this and you
repair my armor
Okay, let's see
Grab a little bit of that
Let's see what do I need What was I doing sweeper sweeper
tag stuck some balls sweeper sweep Yeah, get that sweeper
sweep sweep sweep sweep sweep right straight is this sweeper
like the most powerful 15 seconds detention for you Why do
you actually sound like that guy though?
This is kind of bothering me Oh no, you're no, you sound
like you sound like the principal.
I am the principal.
He is the principal.
He is the law dang No Alright, I'm heading over Sorry about
all the stuff I did.
Please don't call my mom Sorry I said balls like 14 now 15.
What's this?
I had fun come back again Sometimes two Bushi I'm blushing.
Okay, where the fuck?
How do I get across?
Legally.
There it is.
I'm almost there.
God, that's so fast!
Stop running!
I perish!
No!
Let me climb!
Please don't let me drown!
Okay.
We're almost up there.
top balls check don't worry i checked my balls balls have
been checked all right balls have been checked no lumps
we're checking balls yes sushi and bio yes why is there why
is there a full grown man in my balls whoa he's just cross
checking he's thank god you check those balls i mean it's
part of the it's part of the global achievement though you
got to catch like five guys so how oh oh wait that's a level
31 yeah that ain't doing getting that killed how many hours
we have left i haven't been paying attention uh me either
two and a half two and a half okay yeah oh no tom bat's
falling ill oh nine of them is only level 10 that's a goal
let's go oh i have no arrows oh no what the heck wait how do
you do i have enough to make arrows right now i'll make
arrows i just need one arrow to get him out of the sky
that's it i need one wood you need to grab that waypoint oh
hey there's an effigy here i know we get like points for
effigies too for the global right uh yes okay once you get a
flying pal it's really easy to do yeah especially at night
yeah Get over here.
Get over your waypoint
What the heck?
What's going on Lily?
What are you doing?
I'm trying to deal with the pink again What?
I'm battling the pink always at all times Is it even a boss?
No, it's not it's just the strongest boss the pink is just
oh the pink I thought he said pig.
I was like, oh, no We're like doing every time I dodge.
I'm like, oh, I'm out surely and I still get hit.
I'm like, no way Legendary difficulty ping boss.
All right, go kill this sweeper.
Go die.
I only have a pickaxe.
So I'm not helpful.
No, not the babies.
We don't care about the babies.
No!
Oh, God.
I might actually die.
Whoa, whoa.
It's okay.
My dire wolf is okay.
I leveled up.
Woo.
It's okay.
It's like Dark Souls dodging.
Two more balls.
Then I have to farm some ball materials.
Nice.
It's always balls.
Oh, I see.
What am I going to do with all these balls?
No way.
That's not worth it.
I'm not running after him.
Come on.
Dyer wolf.
Nice.
Oh no, he's hungry.
I just have to dodge earlier.
Yeah.
You have to think into the future.
Yeah, exactly.
I have to think everything a little early.
Just think 200 pinyon advance.
Oh no, my pal team is hungry.
Yeah, the fastest way to level up in this game is just to
catch pals.
Like literally just spam catch pals.
Don't worry.
And I'm out of vaults.
One ball left.
Give me that sweeper!
I shall harvest balls.
So proud of you.
Nice.
Go for the dick.
I missed!
Clip!
I got them!
Okay, but don't clip the dick part!
Clip it!
The sweeper!
I grabbed the sweeper!
Wait!
Nice, we did it.
And it feed my fucking wolf.
Alright, nice.
Where is this?
Oh my god.
Alright guys, I got the sweeper.
Another boss down!
Let's go!
I'm so freaking proud of you.
Oh my god, you're so great.
Do you have a...
Do you cheer for how many bosses have you caught yet now?
I've killed one.
Why is this cat attacking?
And grab more.
Nice.
Who's next after sweeper?
What do I have to catch next?
The gumas.
Okay, where is gumas?
Gumas, where?
Where is this?
Come on, get in the boat!
Nice!
Nice guy.
We're doing it.
Where the fuck is the Gumas boss?
Where is it?
This is not helpful.
You should get that check though.
I don't know.
Gumas POW world boss location.
What?
What the fuck is it?
Let me get some stuff away.
Let me steal some of that.
I need some more balls.
What the heck?
We all need balls, don't we?
Yeah.
I'm gonna steal all the balls.
We are in need of balls.
Let's see.
Oh, I need to put away this.
This.
Oh, yeah.
I put some ancient civilization parts away.
Is there anything we need to make in ancient civilization?
No, right?
There will be, but not right now.
Not right now, okay.
You can also make more incubators for the leftover eggs.
And then just tear them down after.
Yeah, if we can make a second incubator, that'd probably be
pretty good.
Don't worry, I'll make it now.
We need cloth and stone.
Can someone get that for us?
Yep.
I can get more.
I'm in the first area, so I can get more lamb.
What is happening?
Get some stone now.
We're on our way to get $500.
Guys, we already have $500.
If we're last place right now, we're already at $500.
Shit, man.
That's amazing.
Yeah, let me grab this.
I can't click this stupid word button.
Oh my goodness.
It's the big craft Yeah, you'll be fine guys.
We're sort of 15th place right now We're 16 teams right
guys, yeah, we're not last guys.
It's cuz we're not last it's guys These things we can do it
so fucking fast.
I'm just saying
See put stone away it okay oh we just got last place
apparently oh no way i could speed run all these bosses and
then we're gonna get out of it tortoise in the hair baby
tortoise in the hair we'll be fine we'll be fine because all
we need is to catch up yeah we're gonna kill like mambo rest
right now
All right, I'm level 19 now.
I'm coming back to base Wait, T must capture it?
Does that mean all of us must have 10?
We all have to catch them.
Oh, we can just drop pals.
It says Dropping pals.
What happened to the base?
Wait, does it mean, like, the To kill?
We're level 12 base now.
Nice.
Clip it!
Clip that!
What a really boring...
Oh, we're level 12 base now.
I love it!
That's cool.
Okay, what do I need to do?
Okay, I need to build the NKBA.
Guys, I still need stone.
Wait, who the fuck used up all the stone that I just put
away?
Large, pelvic.
Who used all the stone that I literally just got for us?
Wait, what?
I literally put in like 18 stone, now there's zero.
Where the fuck are you going, motherfucker?
Last player's gang.
No, but we're playing a long game.
We're playing a long game.
We have a plan.
Oh, if we want to upgrade to level 13.
How do I get him to work?
If you can make us the fluffy pal bed two of them, then we
can be level 13.
I'm making the egg incubator.
That's literally all we need.
It's a level 24 recipe.
It's the plan to be last place.
Make two fluffy palettes.
All right.
I hash.
We got a Knox right now.
I'm making the other egg incubator.
We need more cloth.
And then I can make it.
I'm going to try and find a good moss.
Oh, we can make like 139 cloth.
So I'm going to do that.
Do it now.
Wow.
Okay, what did I want to do?
I already forgot where I was.
Oh yeah, Gumas.
Where the fuck is Gumas?
I'm still trying to figure out where he is.
Boss map.
Pal world boss map.
There you go.
All alpha boss locations.
Oh, wait.
Just the alpha boss?
Fucking finally, bro.
Okay.
All right, Anubis.
Gumas.
Where are you?
Worse sec.
Eliza beat.
No, I need Gumas.
Okay.
I'll go get a walk.
Okay, Dumas is right here.
Okay, I figured it out.
Alright, I'm gonna head over.
He's like right here somewhere.
Achievement list.
Dumas?
What's Dumas?
I don't even know what these bosses are.
Dumas?
Oh, it's like, I love him.
He's like this cool, dumb-looking fish dude.
Oh, man.
He's so stupid looking.
I think I know what you're talking about.
Yeah.
The moment you said the dumb looking fish guy, I'm like,
quite excited.
Oh my God.
He looks like he has no brain cells.
You're not wrong, though.
Uh, where is Dummit?
Let's see.
Yeah.
He's the dented fish.
Blue she's here.
Dirt fish.
I'm gonna crash these guys right now.
Yeah, I can probably take on the Dummit.
I just need to figure out where he is.
the eastern islands i feel like no no are they fighting oh
my god oh this little joltig i want to join into this fight
no oh wait he's still alive okay oh he's on the ice wind
islands really that's really far oh boy uh okay all right
well all right all right we've done chill it we've done Pen
King.
Well, we haven't done Pen King.
Oh, we haven't done Pen King.
Wait, what are you doing right now, Sheriff?
Before I didn't know.
What are you doing right now?
Power leveling.
Oh, okay.
We have to stop eventually, right?
I mean, how many hours we gotta live?
Two?
Or two hours?
Yeah.
Alright.
When do you gotta start capturing?
I can kill bosses.
True.
Yeah, but what are you gonna start?
Start capturing.
You're doing great.
I got two only.
What do you mean?
You're doing fantastic.
I'm going to make some balls.
I'm trying to find Goumas.
It's like right here somewhere.
Oh, there he is.
All right, here I'll go.
Capturing Goumas.
Yeah, we're just leveling enough to just kill the bosses
back to back.
Yeah, exactly.
But I forgot to.
See, that's what I'm saying.
It's tortoise and the hare.
We've been taking our time, getting everything ready.
Alright, he's over here.
Like, this is organized.
I'm just gonna use him.
Oops.
Ooh.
We have base management.
I get the materials.
Yeah.
We have boss killings.
There you go.
I found my purpose.
I have been defeated by the like, I'm just...
I'm downgraded to a material fetcher.
You know your purpose.
You know it.
I have found my purpose.
There were organized chaos right here.
Guys, clip it.
Got Goobas.
Clip, clip, clip.
Goobas.
And they caught this random fish.
Yeah, I'm doing my part.
What can I say?
We're doing our part.
And I'm easy being laggy.
Okay.
We're doing it.
We got goobas.
Another 10 points.
We can't be last!
I have become one of the pals!
Ain't no way!
No way!
We got another ten!
Ten on the board!
We gotta...
Victory Royale.
Yeah, Fortnite we're about to get down.
Get down!
Alright, Dumont.
Wait, are you getting doing Dumont right now?
PP, are you doing Dumont?
PP.
I'm not.
Okay, okay, I'll get Dumont then.
Alright.
do the lower level bosses and i do the higher level all
right you do the mediums then the mediums are like beacon
and uh aqua patalia fuck okay where the fuck is i need to
make a shield i'm like too reckless oh jesus uh i just fell
through the map well i'm in the water and i'm dead Oh, geez.
Oh, what came out of that egg?
Oh, a Nox.
Oh, nice.
Yeah, do we need to use it?
What the heck?
Nah.
Where the fuck is...
Where the fuck is Dumont?
Where is he?
Don't know.
Dumont.
Power.
I'm gonna make a shield.
Pull up your map YouTube video.
Where is he?
Okay.
Alpha.
Boss.
Yeah, I have no balls.
I couldn't catch it.
Don't say that about yourself.
You value outside of your balls.
Balls are all I have, man.
I just need you to know...
No, no, you're so much more than that.
You're so much more.
You're so much more than just balls.
Guys, tell me where the fuck is Dumat?
I can't fight him!
He's kind of far.
Where are you right now?
I don't fucking know where I am.
He's like past the bamboo groves.
Oh, he's past the bamboo.
I'm not fucking catching that.
That's way too far.
All right, I'm just gonna go for Pen King then.
There's another guy on this, like, lake in the middle of the
ocean, though.
Oh, my God.
It's on a respawn timer right now.
Oh, still?
What?
Probably.
Grinto.
What?
Grintel location.
Yeah, the lag is...
I'm just material, boy.
It's better this way.
I can't even fly a freaking pile, man.
Oh, no.
I figure out where he is, okay.
Let me...
Oh, God, that Lunaris is level 32.
Maybe not.
Don't worry, we won't forget.
We can take the photo any time.
we can take it any time guys do not worry i'm just gonna
kill this guy though i'm not worrying yeah see everybody's
worrying that we're not doing like the baby things right now
like we're doing the hard work yeah we're playing along no
one's believing us what the heck man the base level was like
i don't know how many points but seems like a lot of points
oh my god already right i think we made so many oh my god
that was way too many I don't feel like walking all the way
back.
Made too many wood.
No, there's like so much wood that I immediately became
over-encumbered.
It's like a foul.
Oh, yeah.
Woof.
Okay, I'll put this back here.
It's alright.
Guys, you're supposed to believe in us.
Like you said, not aesthetics.
I'm just going to catch these random pals for levels.
Alright.
Like, I can live...
I'm almost close to a level 30 chicken, guys.
Believe in us.
Let's go.
Well, I mean, you have to be, you know what, it's, yeah,
it's fine.
I'm so close.
Okay, let's see.
Do we have no pals that are picking stuff up?
Oh my god.
I'm not in charge of bases.
That stuff really works.
Yeah, that's terrible.
We also have, like, two of them.
We have the Liz Monk and Vixie just stuck downstairs the
whole time.
Yeah, I think it's this way.
I'm looking at the map to make sure where the fuck this
place is.
Where am I?
Oh my god, I need...
Fox, tell me where I am.
Help me.
How much high quality pal oil you get?
Uh...
Only regular pal fluids.
Dammit drops it, I think.
Selen might have some.
Fuck me.
Jokey might have some.
what do you need me high quality pal oil i have pal fluids
is that what you need i need high quality pal oil high
quality pal oil yeah no i don't have any
don't worry you'll get there yeah we'll get there it's like
when i had to keep calling cassidy mccree or mccree I
believe in you.
Where is this guy?
Which bosses are you guys going after right now?
I'm going for it.
Where is this guy?
Grintail.
Okay.
Oh, he drops high quality power oil to a fellow Grintail
member.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I think I might be able to just buy some.
going the right way i can't tell can't see i'm just surfing
okay cool guys am i going the right way i'm just riding in
the ocean
okay oh my die was dying oh no oh oh okay hey can you stop
not being caught my die was my ass yeah you have to farm it
you can't buy it this is how no i'm pretty sure you can buy
it from one area oh um okay nobody's done azurobe right i'll
do nope guys i might die in the water that's not good that's
called drowning i might drown before you drown in it guys
just one big slurry there's a island there's an island right
there Keep swimming.
Keep swimming.
If you die in the water, does that make the price go up for
like the gamer?
Like, I'm just like...
Well, it's the ocean.
Ah, diluted.
Please!
I should be able to.
I should have enough HP to live through this.
Oh, I do not have enough HP to live through this.
Oh, no.
There was hope.
Briefly.
There was brief hope.
No, I'm almost at the island, too!
Oh, wait, wait, wait, I can crawl.
I can crawl to land.
Pain, misery, absolution.
Can I crawl to...
I can't.
Oh, I'm just dead.
Wait, unless...
Wait, I can!
I can crawl to land!
It'll be fine.
And then she slowly dies on land.
No!
My idol!
So I was like, don't give up!
I think I might give up right here.
I didn't know how to get to- I was lost!
And I got so lost!
Oh no.
Ugh.
It's okay, I can find my items.
I just need to crawl to land right now.
Bro, I swear I just brought so much to the base and now it's
all gone.
Let's go.
What did it go?
Did someone pick up the Nightwing Saddle?
Nope.
Guys, I found the island.
Stone, I mean, not...
I can get my items back.
Because I'm on land now.
I can get my items.
I was like, how do you get lost when you have a map?
I just wanted to get there faster!
All the stone is gone!
Oh shit, I can respawn here!
Yeah, I'd be using the stone to make balls.
Oh my god.
My whole life, I've been working for these stones.
Oh my god, okay.
I figured it out.
That's fucking capitalism.
Stone cold.
Guys, I'm a little cold right now.
I lost my shirt.
Okay, I need to replace my wolf.
I don't need you anymore.
Alright, I'm gonna use the bathroom right back.
Good luck.
Yeah.
Don't fall in.
Don't forget to check your balls.
Check before you get wrecked.
Oh shit, Dyerwolf's okay.
I only get my first Dyerwolf.
Oh yeah, that's stone here.
Nice.
Wait, you know what?
I can make this so much faster.
Oh my god, did you just one shot him?
What's wrong with you?
My pals are too aggressive.
That's like the worst part is like you get to a certain
like...
That's one thing that Nintendo did right with Pokemon is
that you get to a certain level and it just makes it so you
can catch stuff easier without like the lift monks.
Because all my pals just one-shot everything and then it's
like impossible
Can anyone like does anyone have a quill burn on them right
now and can they give it to me?
Uh-uh.
Oh, no, I just want a quill burn.
What is a quill burn?
The the fire not fire but one of the the dragons for flight
Sure forking can you just cancel my saddle?
Well, I don't I don't cancel anyone's saddle.
There was no like in here there's a cowardly victim right
here that was nothing all right you're right I'm making a
saddle wow you're gonna blame a V-tuber your chat will not
like that I can't believe your chat your chat's not gonna
like that no they will like that they'll spam they'll spam
evil
alright let's see I'm gonna grab get my shit back dying was
a strat it made me closer to the boss all right i am not
using this boar to ride him fast i'm using this boar to mine
out here wait chipper what level are you right now 29 29 oh
you can catch the mamos you can like kill the mamos thing
soon yeah pretty much i want to make a gun first and i also
need to make high i need him i need ingots to make high
resistant armor and then i can go and buy high quality metal
so i can make a gun and then i can buy ammo everything
there's so much to this yeah but we're not supposed to kill
everything we're supposed to catch things but i can kill
them and then catch them because i'm killing them oh wait
where's the logic wait there's my stuff though boom So I was
like, I want to make a gun first.
A true American.
He's Canadian!
In no time.
Alright, nice.
I got my stuff.
You're free of boo.
That's all it is.
Where the fuck is the gruntail?
It's right here.
Efficiency.
I want to get a flying pal so bad.
I want to get that quill burn.
wonder where the closest one is closest one is like near the
bridge area oh really like one of the bridges from what i
remembered canada is simply north united states it's
america's hat okay should be near here where's that live
monk statue oh god i'm gonna fucking drown again why not the
fucking why not this again
yeah i should probably spec into way quite a bit now that i
have found my purpose well did we meet did we use around
here i've had more eggs oh it is an empty here grab that why
did it have to fall have we pet anything yet no no and we're
petting so we can just get like grab all our pals and just
Petting them at the end.
Yeah, like at the last 30 minutes just start petting No,
they they removed that feature for North America.
We couldn't be trusted with it What petting pals?
Petting pals.
What do you guys do?
What do we do?
Dude, you don't know about that?
There's like so many games out of Japan where they have like
a petting feature Whether it's like for animals or for
people question mark, but like they just you they just
remove that feature.
It's not manly enough.
Why?
Wait, what are you guys doing with the padding feature?
What are we?
Yeah, honestly, I'm concerned now.
What are we doing with the padding feature?
We're removing that.
I've said too much.
Oh, no.
Are we bad people?
Are we the bad guys?
Yeah.
All right.
I died, but at least I died where I wanted to be.
Out of the fucking water.
over here dog get over here giving them the cake
guys we might be 12 now but like the moment we hit our
fucking breaking point it's gonna go so fast.
Once we start petting the pals we're gonna be in first.
Yeah yeah like you guys might be like wow you guys are only
12 but because this is a long game trust the process yeah
remember We built the foundation for a sturdy house.
I was like, trust the process.
I'm like, where am I?
No, enough about that.
Now you trust the process.
I figured out where I am.
Yeah.
Yeah, get him.
I found the tail.
I found grim tail.
What the?
Oh, shit.
That's a...
Oh, he's level 70.
Wait, he's level 17.
Oh, you don't have to...
Oh my god, you're level 10!
I didn't even realize!
Okay.
You kill him?
No, no, I meant like my fucking wolf is level 10.
It's okay, I got chill tail.
Yeah, because I forgot I killed the other one accidentally.
Uh...
You don't lose your pals when you die.
No, but he died because I drowned him accidentally.
Oh, she's putting him in the rehabilitation.
Oops.
So I have to replace him for a little bit.
Go chillin' go.
I need to go make the...
Man, I need a flying mount.
Yeah, I've been working on that too.
I'm just gonna go grab one of the shitty pigeons from the
start.
That's a good idea.
That's all I got, okay?
That's all I have.
That just can't be choosers.
go fox go i don't have a weapon still because i keep whoa
whoa whoa whoa whoa he fucking almost one shot me holy shit
do you have a shield no we don't need shields shields are
for losers i say as i'm about to die oh wait do we still
need people do we have all of our people No, we need 10.
I think we still need...
Okay, okay.
We need 10.
No, no, we need 20.
We need 20.
Oh, shit, really?
Yeah.
We need 20 in the viewer's range.
Oh.
Wait, can I catch him?
He's definitely dead.
Oh, okay, cool.
Well, not my fault.
I caught two more humans.
Nice.
More balls, less shields.
That's right.
I'm going to make a shield.
Oh, please don't get involved.
Look at our base is so laggy There's just too much stuff
going on.
We have so much shit.
Oh my god
Lord Because none of the pals are picking up the items so
our base is just like it's time for you to pick it up.
It's in shambles Okay, come on.
Come on Come on Please at least give me that I got it!
One!
Clip it!
That's all that matters.
What is my purpose?
You mine rock.
Oh no!
I did my job!
Okay, now they grab my shit again.
Because their fire Pokemon is not cooking half the time.
Oh.
That's not good.
It's time to grab it.
more sounds like yeah sounds like i might i might make
another base and just have it only for iron and stuff yeah
yeah because i need it for stuff okay where's my that's fine
that's fine my other die will be 16.
mine all right we got okay we got grinta i need the azurobe
they still figure out where the Fuck, Azarob is.
He's near the bridge.
Near the bridge.
He spawns in the water.
Okay.
Alright.
That doesn't really help me too much, but I get it.
The bridge that's to, like, the north west of our house.
North west of our house.
Head to the bridge and then go to the water that's to the
west of the bridge.
Where's west?
This way.
Okay.
I'm going to grab my stuff real fast.
I
use boar Boar fast Look how fast I'm demolishing this rock
With the boar Yeah Trust in the process Just trust the
process Yeah Trust the fucking process Come on We might not
be like Very high placement right now But like in the last
hour You're gonna see a skyrocket Yeah It's over here Wait
where even is the Oh there it is Okay where's my stuff there
where did I go there it is okay where the fuck is the fire
guy oh he's over there what is he doing wait there's an
effigy right here too and now we deliver come here shit make
make ingot you've literally one task just making it yeah try
making them do it and they refused Just they were like no
Spank it into them.
He like looked at it was like yeah, that's nice.
I trust the process and then did nothing I think a lot of
them are just getting fucked on pathing.
Yeah, I think our face is like a little crazy I'm gonna get
rid of some stuff crazy to be fair.
I'm just gonna get rid of some stuff That shit I didn't want
to kill him Like we're not really using like the mill and
shit So I'm just gonna get rid of them if we need them we
can just rebuild them isolated island cavern.
Is that part of the dungeons we have to do?
no wait why can't i pick up more of these oh oh there there
it all goes where the fuck is the it should be up here okay
I need to get the nightwing okay I'm gonna try and find the
azurope right now is it because of these okay where the fuck
oh it's this way
How many hours do we have left?
I don't have my timer out.
An hour and 45.
I think at an hour we gotta start like actually.
Yeah, yeah.
Doing a bunch of these.
Alright, Captain.
I will stone production through the roof.
Okay, I'm gonna actually make a weapon.
Catching all the stone.
I'm gonna make a weapon for holy shit this is laggy.
wait did you go back to the base yeah yeah i'm i'm
destroying things right now because it's really bad okay
i'll grab this okay i really row okay i need no one's making
any of the weapons workbench how dare you ask me how i'm
doing i'm mining rock what do you think you think she's
doing right now how do you think where the fuck will he
cross this is my life now i'm so slow why is it so laggy oh
my
shield i thought you said you didn't need one no you're no i
was i'm just i was just a ha ha joke okay i was just testing
it was just he funny just doing a little little he ha ha
yeah it was just a joke why are you guys so serious okay why
are you so serious over here where the where's the crafting
table uh there's two there's one right by the pal box and
then uh which which craft table i need like a regular
crafting this is just this love yeah okay there's a oh hold
on i'm building another one i'm building a high quality one
i'm just gonna make or i was trying to anyway here we go all
right high quality crafting table right here nice and then
the speed should go up too we don't have like 30 30 gravity
where's the where's the other one right in front of the mine
the stone mine yep this all right go for it okay naturally
you make my shield okay Wrath.
Gathering.
Gathering all my other pals.
I am rock.
Gathering bitches.
I am become rock.
I'm having a good time, Lily.
I love Power World.
Yay!
Yippie!
I'm just glad to be a great, great, innocent.
You matter!
One of these days I hope our stamina runs out when I jump
off this cliff.
I have our... I finally have a weapon, guys.
I'm doing it.
Finally have a weapon!
Wait, what happened to the fire?
I'll put another one here.
I feel like we should make another, like...
What is it called?
The orthing?
Orthing?
We should make another...
The furnace yeah, actually we should we should ask we should
ask sure to make the better one.
Oh, yeah I think that they should I think you actually have
it unlocked already Do you have like the the nice furnace?
I think it's level Let's find out I don't think so hold on
what level is that one?
I get it at 34.
Oh, okay.
Okay.
All right.
What level are you right now?
We need like three more power beds our guys are fucking
stressed out got it Okay, now I have arrows.
Let's go
All right craft craft craft craft craft craft craft My job
of company morale yes
After 20 years, I finally did it.
I have a weapon Yeah Now I can be a true asset Pala Oil.
I have six Pala Oil by the way.
I can't believe she's following my footsteps.
I can't believe it.
I'm learning so much.
Is there any more Pala?
I need to make some Pala Balls.
They grow by so fast.
Pala Ball Time.
That's not it.
Wait, that's a claw farmer.
They're not... Oh, there you go.
Uh...
Here.
I'm gonna put more chest so I can give you guys the high
quality Pala Oil.
Okay All right, put that away that fixed the fire problem we
it's like making fire now.
Yay You know we have to discover fire We got fire now we got
fire now When do I get a crossbow?
I need a pal that can fucking Oh shit.
I already pressed oh cool cool.
I'm gonna make it No, I can't because I don't have any of it
all right get over here oh wait not you actually sweet i
heard sweet but it's like the strongest shit ever did you
did you beat azurob azurob nope okay okay are you doing
azurob right now maybe maybe i'm thinking about it yeah go
for it okay i'm gonna go i'm gonna go grab the other stuff
then okay do i have arrows let's see i have gigaspiers oh i
don't have gigaspiers it's the one afterwards the mega
spears there it is i don't have mega spears never mind uh i
need i still need a quill burn our like wooden stone
production is really good though okay where is quill thank
you thank you i think that's I think so.
Great job.
Amazing.
Actually goaded.
Where is...
Where do you unlock?
Okay, I need to find a quill...
Where to find quillburn.
Where are you?
Wait, not quiver.
Where...
What's not that one?
Okay, dragon, pal world.
Uh, mount.
Fuck this.
I need a flyer.
Yeah, when you get a saddle though, That's the other
question.
The saddle for him.
Van Worm!
So it's not my list.
There we go.
I need to find a van worm.
Yeah!
They're near the desert, I think.
Okay.
I can...
I could be wrong.
All right.
I'm getting a van worm.
That's the closest.
It's like next to us, right?
It's right here.
One more rock.
Oops.
That should be where Van Worm lives.
Van Worm!
I'm just flying away for a second.
Let's see.
Van, Van, Van, Van, Van, Van, Van, Van, Van, Van.
Van, Van, Van, Van, Van, Van, Van.
I also want to get a Van worm.
It's where I am at.
Oh, okay, wait, let me look on the map.
It should be.
From what my Google tells me.
Oh, wait, can I see where you are on the map?
Oh, wait, yeah, I can.
Okay, it's near where I was heading to anyway.
That's where I was going anyway.
It's all on mozzarella.
What the fuck are you?
Bad worm.
There it is.
All right.
Blah.
Don't worry.
I have a bow now.
Let's fucking right get over here.
Come on.
Get over here.
Oh, shit!
Oh, that's not our shield.
That's fine.
That's my shield.
rock oh pal merchant just died that sucks for him no please
get over here oh actually i guess i should probably catch
them oh my god that's if they're out here anyway i should
probably catch them that's unfortunate please no i get him
what i'm having a little bit of trouble amy right now are
you are you are you
Guys, can someone pick me up?
Please, I really don't want to rock back here.
PP, can you pick me up?
Yeah, wait, wait, pick you up from where?
Pick me up.
I'm downed.
Oh, shit, where are you?
Well, let me find you.
I'm where the van worms are.
Please.
Okay.
My wolf killed.
No, my wolf killed them.
No!
PP, please.
I'm just catching these men.
Never mind, I'm gonna give up.
I don't think I can reach you in time.
I'm gonna give up.
No!
My wolf killed him too!
Was it a shiny?
No, I just wanted a van worm.
Oh.
Okay.
See, where did I die?
It wasn't so far.
Why am I gonna open a window?
Holy shit, it's hot in my room.
Passion.
Catching run rooms is a struggle.
It's stressful, man.
I'm just trying to catch humans.
Alright, you know what?
Go out there, dude.
Alright.
Get in the ball!
Where the fuck?
Oh my god, I was getting shot at.
Please.
Why?
Why is this man refusing?
Get in the ball!
Did you ask him nicely?
Get in the ball, man.
Yeah, he clearly didn't consent to this.
Sentient.
Sentient invisible gun.
He clearly didn't consent to it.
Pretty, pretty please.
Can I put you in my human circus?
Human circus?
We have like 20.
Thank you.
Isn't that, wait, isn't that one of the goals that we have
to put them in like a little cage?
We need 20.
That's why I was like, do we have 20?
I just caught 2 or 3, I think.
I have, like, I have, like, 3?
I think 3 or 2 on me.
Hmm.
Now I need to find a fucking bambworm again.
God damn it.
Oh, I wish I had to chill it.
Then I could, like, swim over there.
I really need to get some pal that can do logistics.
Oh, for real?
I don't need it.
Sweet.
Yeah, just need it.
Next time we're at the base.
Yeah, I'll just put it in the thing.
Yeah, I'll grab it.
Thank you.
It's a bad worm.
It's a poacher berry.
Boom.
Okay, I hope for now we have enough rock.
We have 800 rock.
It's gonna have to amount to something right here.
It has to be.
It has to.
We must be able to get something out of it.
Oh So I killed those two bad worms that I never found any
left or not Please Let's see these are kind of useless Can I
replace bosses somewhere around here?
Oh The bees oh wait, no, no, there's an azurope right here.
Okay.
Yeah, that's the one Oh, there it is bad worm Get him Go
wait, that's not my Here it is No, no, please don't please
don't shoot him.
Please don't
Stupid silly flag.
I'm gonna catch you.
I see you are doing amazing progress Yeah, I caught another
I'm gonna catch a human I'm gonna kill you.
No, oh I killed it the week my bad Alright, I got two...
It's okay, I got two syndicate thugs out of this.
I might not have got a Van Worm, but I caught two syndicate
thugs.
Make Oort.
I'm so sad.
I just want a Van Worm.
Are you still in the Van Worm area?
Yes!
Yes, I am!
Oh, dear.
They killed the only one I found!
Oh, hey, there's an electric egg.
What do you mean my kneecaps are backwards?
What does that even mean?
What?
What does that?
What kind of insult is that?
What?
Where are you?
Please, it's nighttime.
Okay, this time.
Please don't kill him.
Please, that's all I ask.
Looking for a...
Travel point over here.
Okay.
I'm gonna use...
I'm gonna use my mega sphere.
Oh, I got one!
I have five balls.
I got bad worm!
Yay!
I have discovered flight!
GG.
Okay, there you go.
I've discovered flight.
Okay, let me put the chillin for you.
Okay.
Thank you.
I'm I replaced it with a life monk Okay, thanks and then or
lift monk and then we put a van where I'm here And then
That's fine Okay See, you need to make a where's the pal
crafter Pal crafter?
Yeah, pal gear crafter I need to use it.
Oh, uh, you gotta remake it.
Oh all right let me do i have here it's right here but i'm
using it oh it is where are you oh there you are okay are
you making i'm gonna help too thank you we'll all work
together we're all gonna work together we got this we can do
this we're all in this together okay i'm gonna go kill the
catch the azurob actually what's how much time do we have
left actually one hour i think i have an hour mark we gotta
like speedrun some captures on it we're at an hour and a
half once i make my pistol like speedrun capture shit oh
shit hey yeah okay now i'm gonna make my saddle uh where the
fuck is the vanworm saddle we need spears No!
There it is.
Oh, I just made it.
Come on, dude.
Not here.
No!
Okay, I need...
My quest for Van Worm also ends early.
Not you.
This...
No!
Where the fuck is our fire?
We're the fuck over fire ones.
Uh...
Let's see.
It's okay to just...
Trust the process, man.
It's okay.
Just trust the process.
No, when you keep saying trust the process, I'm starting to
trust the process less and less.
That's when you got to trust the process even more.
Wait, does Vamworm do fire?
Oh, shit, it does.
Get out of here.
I didn't even realize Vamworms are fire.
I don't care what fuck about you.
What kind of fire?
What level fire is it?
but our other ones aren't kindling it right now.
All right, do your thing.
I need...
Who's hungry over there?
Oh, it's eeping.
It's eepy.
I thought I was stuck because I kept seeing it wasn't
hungry.
I'm like, man, then go eat something.
This fucking meat forehead.
Wait, what?
This is just eed.
Am I blind?
I need...
Where's the chillit saddle?
I need like six more fucking...
I can get to if anyone has extra.
If I can make my van more sadder.
Wait, do I get the XP for capture if I direct palates into
my bar I haven't captured yet?
I don't...
I think no, you don't get the capture rate, right?
You don't get it.
Let me see, let me grab this one in my team.
Very slowly.
Nope.
I do not.
Fuck.
If you don't trust us, you don't believe us.
in us you're not real you're not true ones yeah what the
hell yeah how can you not trust this process i know do you
not see our long game here i know this is like we're not
doing short term here we're all we have long term goals yeah
we've worked really hard towards this yeah this goal exactly
tell them all right please be fast your vanworm so i can
ride you please i need like two more I need one more Blow
Wait where's the pal girl Palgear bench now?
Oh is that one over there Uh no that's repair Oh wait there
it is nice okay I finally Right I died a lot for this win
Like come on man No Oh shit I'm sorry can I help you Okay I
don't think I don't think we're Okay thank God okay I can I
can make it down my fucking saddle
oh pen king fuck yeah all right we get we got pen king yeah
oh did you get it yeah did you see it did you see it oh wait
no we didn't beat pen king we hatch pen king oh we had to
capture no that's different very different Very different.
I was gonna be like, sure, for it didn't.
I can probably go fight Pen King now if he's respawned.
He's probably respawned.
He probably is.
It's been like two hours.
He's probably almost three hours.
He's probably back.
Yeah.
Is there a hatching list?
There's no hatching list.
I'm pretty sure.
Is there?
No.
I don't know.
I don't think there's an achievement for hatching.
There's only four things we need to hatch that give us.
Don't touch that.
Achievements.
What is it?
Anubis Something, something, something, something I thought
that was for breeding Or unless that counts Wait Anubis I
know you can do Even from early game But I'm You need the
The fat green guy And the queen bee Okay Small settlement
Where the fuck did I see the azure Oh there it is Are you
going to get the azure orb Or am I getting the azure orb I
have to go pick up my stuff If you get there first Okay I'll
get the azure orb then Help Oh dude the azure I'm having a
clerical area right now where I can't seem to oh shit I
can't seem to stay alive whoa shiny oh it's like a shiny
extra points whoa he like spawned next to me ow what shiny
is it that fuck oh shiny fuck love it I was like what am I
hearing oh shit no no no no no no no no no no I might die no
please please only make it catch you please please clip it
clip it I got him it's fine I got the fuck and I died next
to the respawn beacon knew you could do it it was worth it
oh what the fuck was that boom what was that I leveled up
I'm finally managing kill stuff yeah finally you're strong
enough i'm trying man i'm here nice i can't figure out the
rhythm to dodge abilities oh yeah because you have to figure
it out 200 200 i feel like my ping isn't consistently high
either because like sometimes i'm like okay you know what i
think i figured it if i just dodge earlier then sometimes
it's too early i'm like what how never figure it out you'll
always be you'll always be guessing all right let's see oh i
but if it's far below me i don't get air i can get heat all
right are you getting oh are you getting the azurob now or
uh i'm still picking up my gear all right i'll go grab it
this serpent is stupid slow i wanted to use the chill it but
since i haven't caught one uh it doesn't show up in my
saddle list oh you have okay that sucks rip it doesn't suck
all right rip now i can kill you where is it all right oh i
went the wrong way fuck i keep going the wrong way oh dizzy
i'm gonna get this one i'm flying i'm soaring
what the oh no stop i don't want to die all right kill my
pal Here we go.
It's this way.
No, I didn't forget about the reincarnated guy.
I literally marked him.
Don't worry, chat.
Yeah, we could do those group photos easy.
Yeah, it's just a photo.
Yes.
Wait, do we have a camera option or, like, does photo mean,
like, we just take a...
We just screenshot it.
What?
I don't know.
I'm sure a clip will do just fine.
There he is.
Azuro.
Oh.
I don't know what to tell you man my balls just play through
it what your balls are just too smooth man my balls are too
smooth I have to make some oh my god I fucking what I got
fucking hit there how oh no I'm having ball troubles oh no
not the whoa no please Please don't...
Don't kill me.
Please!
How am I missing?
Okay.
I gotta focus on dodging now.
Please, gruntail.
For the love of God.
No!
You killed him!
How could you?
Okay.
Will you kill the boss?
No, my van worm, I was like, really?
I was about to catch him?
and then uh my pal my pal went a little bit uh murder
murdery it's okay i know how that feels no the van worm so
thank god we still have the pen king killer boss now we can
still retry we have like yeah but they they respawned all
right yeah yeah yeah so worst case if you try now we can try
again in like an hour whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa bro i
keep dying why please
no more catching pals only killing pals my new motto oh i
could get this human he's only level four i might get killed
how many more do we need for humans give him a new hole four
on me you have four on you yeah yeah wait let me look i have
i have one two three four five six i have six humans we need
20 in total Where's the weapons work bench at?
I don't think we have one.
We did.
Oh, we did.
Oh, yeah.
We did.
We disassembled it.
I'll make one.
I got it.
I need three nails.
Grintel, no, you're drowning!
I can make nails.
I can make some two.
I'm just one right now.
Take this for me, sweeper.
Sweep, sweep, sweep.
Okay, sweep.
I'm just killing these humans.
but this god is just like whatever bro you do you yes okay
that's fine 55 where you're going stop azurob done i got
another i got another clip clip clip i got azurob all right
what do i need to do to make those bear traps i think i
should go catch those uh lambows lamb balls is there nothing
bear trap bear trap i need ingots all right we can make
ingots yeah all right we got Azarob, Grintel, Dumas...
Wait, did we get the Dumas already?
Oh, Dumas... Oh, I'm gonna go fucking get the Dumas.
Fuck this.
I should be able to make it.
We're sleeping?
Yeah, it makes them an easy target.
What do you mean?
Alright.
I need to figure out where Dumas is.
Get those points.
No balls are struggling.
I know.
I'm out of struggling balls, man.
always play struggle city stop talking about my balls it's
making me nervous I'm having performance anxiety it's
getting the balls are getting smaller they're shriveling up
they're turning to bubbles you're not helping chat I'm
making them nervous chat say something say something
negative about your balls it'll make us feel better yes yes
please yes please You cause this problem, you have to fix
it.
Yeah, it's your fault.
It's your fault.
Take responsibility.
Okay, let's see.
I need to...
What do I need to do?
If I swear, then I usually struggle like this.
What the fuck is...
Where's my...
Where's my Google Maps?
Duma, Ice, Frost...
They spelled...
They spelled one of the...
Boss's names wrong on the thing by the way.
Oh, it's here.
Okay.
Yeah, I think it's okay.
Yeah, it's like doom mud Okay, I know where to go.
Okay, I'm gonna get I'm gonna fucking just ride all the way
there Here, okay, I can even I'm gonna steal your gigaspir.
This is gonna be important Whoever's gigaspir is this I'm
stealing it take it.
Hey, what the fuck?
It wasn't even yours What do you mean?
It's not mine.
I know it wasn't yours.
I literally made it.
No, it wasn't Oh, captain, my captain.
I don't think it was yours.
Maybe I just won't kill any bosses.
Wait, okay, wait, I'm stuck.
What the fuck?
My Van Worm was stuck.
Wait, there you go.
Van Worm, where are you?
My Van Worm is like, crooked.
My Van Worm's slanted.
My Van Worm is bent.
I bent my Van Worm.
My Van Worm's slanted.
Stop looking.
He's trying his best, though, can't leave him alone.
He couldn't handle the thighs.
Okay, did you guys get...
Understandable.
I'm not a good day.
Fuck this.
He's like right here anyway.
Do it.
Yeah, they usually slant at one side.
You seem like an expert to slant at vanworms.
Oh, I'm hungry.
I'm hungry.
Fuck, okay.
Oh, I don't want to fight them.
All right.
I'm going to go back to...
I'm going to build bear traps.
Nice.
How many ink do I need?
I need...
How many...
Wait, was it 10 or 5?
Landballs.
I already used 93 arrows?
Oh, no.
I actually put away some of my arrows.
Money's tight.
I can check.
I can check the list.
If anybody knows offhand, though, how many...
How about what?
Landballs?
How many landballs was it 5 or 10?
5.
your five at the same time easy at the wait what do they
mean by at the same time means like i actually in the same
trap wait i actually don't know does someone like clarify
that wait i think we just make five traps and we yeah make
five traps right yeah yeah clarify that for us who knows
what that means i think you just keep the traps up like you
i think you just built the trap oh and Click how the pen
came!
Clip, clip, clip, clip!
Clip, clip!
Clip, clip, clip!
Catch file at the same time...
I guess we could ask the admin what they mean by that?
Because actually I'm confused.
Clarify.
Yeah, I'm actually confused now.
Excuse me.
Can you clarify, please?
Actually.
Oh, there's a...
I'm stuck.
Okay, there we go.
Oh, fuck.
five traps with oh five traps with five different lambels
okay all right that's fine yeah yeah i need to find all
right we're mine let me go this way all right i'm heading
over to the doom mud the mud do mud get over here i don't
need i can get arrows later wait there's an effigy nice i'll
grab that effigy actually.
Nice noise.
My god.
Why is my character so wet?
What happened?
Wait, wait, wait.
I'm literally, I'm literally
First off, which pal is this?
Dude, wait, can you see my- Oh my god, dude, I was so juicy.
What just happened?
What the fuck?
Sure, for sure.
I was juicy.
Dang!
My slime was leaking out of every pore.
Oh no.
Hey, what hell level is this?
Level 30, I can't- That's- That's good, right?
It's supposed to be juicy, and then you might want to be dry
and like all crunchy and stuff.
Ew.
Wait.
Can you imagine?
I- I really don't want to.
No thanks.
I just, I don't know.
I don't think you're thinking, I don't know.
Personally.
I don't know about that one.
You know, maybe.
Okay, what was the one that we needed to do together?
That dungeon, the ravine one, right?
Do we want to do the ravines?
The ravine dungeon?
If someone can find them.
Yeah, we need to find the ravine dungeon.
If you know where it is.
Yeah, one of us find the ravine dungeon.
We can do it.
I'm gonna ask Google.
I love asking Google.
Yeah, if you find it, I fly.
Is there the ravine grotto?
You can look at the word, Doc.
Because we're like right there.
I might be standing in front of it, even.
I mean, you still have to you have to find it still.
We have to find it.
It's not like it's just there.
Pfft.
wait how much time we have left actually an hour okay i'm
gonna after an hour i'm gonna try i'm gonna power level to
30.
so my chicken can be level 30.
after i get that doom one come on stay in the ball stay in
the ball shit pals are stored in the balls no no i think the
spot that i died at is dungeon so I'm just gonna go there
and check yeah I mean just mark the dungeon and then we can
head over together all right I'm like I'm like I can just
find in a waypoint wait can I open this yeah okay nice it's
arrows it's exactly what I needed recon wait a minute
actually yeah I don't care about these guys
I need to get to the fucking...
Where am I?
Am I close?
Am I close to Doomad?
Doomad.
I'm not close to you.
Oh wait, can I grab that ingot now?
Did he finish making it?
Where am I?
Nobody made it!
Okay, why are these tiles so fucking worthless?
Still fire piles.
Why are these tiles so fucking worthless?
Whoa!
Make the ingot!
No, they matter.
They matter.
They matter, bro.
Don't push them too far, dude.
We don't have the butcher knife.
We can't hide the evidence.
Butchering pals is not an exploit.
It is above board.
I mean, they know what they did.
It's more like what they didn't do.
Isn't one of the achievements is all of us have to butcher a
how wait really is that global is it I think it's global I
mean we can we do that tomorrow oh no that's oh no that will
suck that will suck so bad that'll be so terrible for us to
do like ethically too right yeah all right just that's why
we catch those five lambos yeah we just catch them all and
then we just butch it.
Yeah, exactly.
Dude, that's perfect with the traps.
I am at the dungeon.
I'm going to see if this is the one we want.
But I think it is.
This is the...
Reveen Grotto.
It's right here.
Oh, it is.
It is.
Okay.
Yeah, then we can do it.
Okay, we can do it now.
We can do it now.
Oh, I put a marker.
I don't know if you can see my markers, but I put it on
there.
I cannot.
You cannot.
just stay where you are and then we're heading over yeah i
know the waypoint
huh oh there it is oh my god there it is
lamb bolts what lamb bolts we never had any lamb bolts what
exactly what what do you mean yeah what do you mean hey i'm
here all right i'm heading over to be happy so you know it'd
be unethical for us to them so we just we're gonna have to
eat them you know that sounds pretty it's the morally right
thing to do all right we're heading over to let's all head
over to uh small pp ravine wait but we all have to do for
the dungeon yeah i know but you guys have to wait until i
get the thing okay all right what do you wait how long yeah
we have to all of them i know all right how long do you
think you'll be ready i don't know soon ish all right while
you're doing that and then we'll I'll go back to getting
fragments.
I'm gonna try and find Duma still.
Duma time.
Duma Duma.
Oh shit, get over here.
Okay, this way.
Here I go.
Duma!
Make sure the dungeon doesn't despawn though.
It has like a specific time to despawn.
Oh, okay.
Let me see.
little little because I know it does despawn yeah okay what
happened to it despawns though like the holes we know it
just we have to find another oh for real yeah because
there's like a timer oh that sucks okay um the amount of
time we have until this I found a large scorching egg oh we
got we got a ton of time it's like two minutes.
Okay, nice.
Easy.
I have a large scorching egg.
Do we have time to hatch it?
Yeah.
All right.
I found a huge scorching egg.
Okay, we should hatch that first, then.
Even if we don't, we can set it and it will still cook.
I found Quiver.
I'm going to kill this.
While we're not around.
It will still cook.
Yeah.
I should hold down cooking it.
Technically, that's not against the rules.
Wait, is Quiver in the list?
See, Uh, it is.
Okay, I'm gonna go catch her at the quiverin right now.
Alright, let's hope I don't die.
Let's go.
Oh, wait, that's my fucking fist.
There you go.
Quiverin!
Oop!
Oh, shit.
I think he'll be fine.
Oh, shit!
I don't think I'll be fine.
Come on.
Oh, I don't have arrows.
Why do I keep forgetting to bring arrows?
Please don't kill me.
Oh no, I'm too strong.
He's dead.
Oh well.
Oh no.
This is what it is.
No!
Please sweeper.
Sweep, sweep, sweep.
Ready?
Alright, I'm catching this quiver and I can head over.
I'm already, I'm still pretty close to it, so if you come to
this location, you'll be pretty much there.
Oh, yikes.
Give me a sec.
I'm trying to catch this quiver and then I'll be ready.
I'm almost there.
Sweet, buddy, girl.
No!
Yeah.
Yeah, what is our ranking now?
My chat says that our ranking has not been updated.
Well, to be fair, we haven't really been doing any
achievements.
We've just been, like, progressing.
I got quiver and clip clip clip.
I got quiver and The cutest fucking pal in the game.
I would die for that thing Yeah, they're so fucking cute.
Okay, I'm heading over a dungeon Okay I'm loading my
inventory.
I'm trying to find a The waypoint and I can be there Oh boy.
I have to cut some traveling to do Let's try Lily's there.
I'll head on over Alright, I'm walking back over.
Um, I'm actually little bit south of it so um go north of my
position okay okay i'm just grabbing arrows and then i
should be good okay i think it's because i left it in one of
these boxes right i must be a box filled of arrows yeah i
knew it all right oh there's a raid oh a passing relaxing
relaxerous oh that's not good i guess we should kill them we
can catch some of them too they give us a shift on a high
quality of work.
Yeah.
Oh, there he is.
Yeah, there's a relaxer.
It's right here.
How many?
I see him.
I don't know.
I see one.
It might just be one.
He's like AFK.
He's not running over.
I think he's stuck.
I think they're actually I'm just gonna kill this one.
Oh.
Alright, I'm just gonna kill this one then.
I'm pretty sure he's just stuck.
A raid of one.
Let's go.
Oh, he is definitely stuck.
Oh,
shit.
We're like, Soros can breed Anubis.
With what?
I caught one of the Relaxesaurus.
Is the raid done?
I caught one of them.
That's the hurt.
There's the other one.
Hey.
It's done.
It was two.
Wow, what a big raid.
let's go i'm ready okay then wait for shy lily to get there
yeah i'm making quite some traveling to do all right i'm
making some beer then yes i got my van worm let's go very
good yeah after this i'm gonna go try and catch those bosses
all right which what where are you starting off on uh i
don't know which ones have you done i've done like the all
like the easy ones to i got penking uh gumas weepy chill it
azurobe uh grintel and quivern
so a lot of the ones at the bot like the bottom are not
taken the medium 10 10 20 20 30 100 what level are you now
sure for uh 31 okay yeah you've got 200 points it looks like
according to my chat we can tackle the medium okay i'm
heading over to Peepie now for the dungeon.
I got you.
Wait, am I wearing the wrong...
Oh, I can upgrade armor now?
Really?
Oh, I can.
Metal armor.
I'll do that later.
I mean, the dungeon has to be, like, super easy, so it
doesn't matter.
Alright, let me find you.
Alright, I'm heading over to a small peepie.
Are we all heading over?
Okay.
On my way to a small peepie.
Come to me.
Let me just unlock the waypoint for...
Whenever we have to be around this area.
We're sure for it.
Is taking a picture global or day one?
For the resurrected dude?
The resurrected dude is day one.
Okay.
So we need to take a picture.
We're at the one hour mark so we have to like speed run,
start speed running now.
It's bedding hours.
Trying to find the entrance again.
At least I marked it on my map, but it's to the right.
It's over.
This way.
I'm just following you.
It's like this way.
It says we have to complete it together.
I'm coming.
Oh, it's dark now.
Hold on.
Okay, it's over this way.
I'm going to catch five humans with level 10 or higher.
I have two humans that are level 10.
Oh Yeah, didn't you guys have little ten humans?
There's a bunch of syndicates over here that we can catch.
Yeah, we can do that later then All right, and then it's
over here It's around this ridge somewhere So do we just
have to complete the dungeon?
I can't really see the person in the dungeon.
We have to complete it.
It's just complete a ravine So we need to speed run and get
to the egg end.
It's over.
Does anybody have a fire pal?
I do.
Yeah, I actually didn't bring any Oh, here it is.
It's right here.
Reveen Grotto.
In we go.
My game crashed!
No!
I think if we wait here, you can enter.
Okay, okay, okay.
My game, it was a corrupt data.
Everything's falling apart.
No!
It's just there!
I didn't fight you guys again.
I can't believe it's all Doki's fault.
That's crazy.
Yeah, wow.
What the heck?
She was churning this whole time.
i was trolling so high where the fuck is okay here you go
all right i'm back i need to find you guys again oh my god
i'm back wait what where do i save where does it save me i'm
loading in thank god i wasn't hosting come on load faster
why is it taking so long
guys it's taking a while this is not good should I restart
it do I restart uh probably because your internet's still
working here I have no pickaxe I'm gonna restart uh I have a
pickaxe oh my god did the game fucking crash please please
power should I just go field bosses then or i guess like
what are you guys wait do we have to complete it as in like
all of us has to be at the end okay okay no i meant like at
the boss that's what i meant working towards the boss like
we just have to be at the boss together we just all have to
kill the boss together yeah we can just go find the boss
room okay i'm here oh my god i can't see though where is it
oh where is this where is it i'll come outside i don't i
can't see right here there you go is it here okay I'm in
nice all right now we run to the end all right okay I'm in
all right doggy doggy's here let's go doggy is there you can
use her a bird I think he's gonna be oh no I think this
thing is slower than walking duck all the time i can oh no i
think we could we can catch syndicate though we can catch
these dudes though yeah but we don't have we it's not like
man like it's not uh what we need now uh why is my little
water snake so slow you love water all right go fast go fast
little guy oh it's because it's the nighttime
Sorry.
We'll just wait.
We can catch this in here.
We're a bit slow.
I'm on this little like noodle, this little parasitic
noodle.
We'll just wait a little.
Sure for an hour here now.
That's our woolly pop.
He's sleeping.
He's eepy.
I'm just looking across the way like it's some sort of like
Indiana Jones adventure, but it's just shyly on the other
side oh my god all right we're here i'm stuck oh she's stuck
too too fat now we kill now we kill now we kill all right
let's go die who's catching this oh he's so freaking cute
though i love the sweepers man all right they're so cute i
can catch the oh all right just this one guy i'm gonna take
him out right now is his he is his health not going down for
anybody else the week hatch pinkin yeah we we caught the
raid i caught their boss
whoa you guys almost fucking killed him boom did we catch
him i got it we did it we finished the dungeon clip clip go
clip clip do we have to take a screenshot or anything No,
it's just clip.
Requires no dungeon treasure.
It says...
Oh, you already got it.
That's right.
Okay.
It says requires screenshot or clip, so we're good.
All right, cool.
All right.
Do we need to do any other dungeons?
Is there any other...
Yeah, we have to find the mountain stream.
I don't know where it is.
Okay, mountain stream.
Oh, give me a sec.
I'm going to go...
You should...
Do the thing.
Yeah, you should start doing bosses.
All right.
I know where mountain stream is.
I'll go search for an entrance.
Okay.
I'm just gonna power level the 30 real fast.
I...
Oh shit, wait.
I didn't do that in...
I'll attempt to level up a little.
Oh wait, um...
Lily, can you try and catch level 10 so the ticket thugs?
We need... I have two on me.
So we need three more.
What do we need?
Level 10... Level 10 humans.
Let me see what level the humans are that I have at least.
I have two level 10 humans.
I'll check.
You have to catch them at 10?
Can we just level them?
Oh, it has to be caught.
I'm going to go to the beginning and just...
Actually, do I have enough for the lantern?
I lantern.
I do.
Ow, fuck.
Maybe 13.
Alright, I got a loot moon.
I want to craft the lantern.
Wait, what level do you need to be for the lantern?
Um...
No.
Let's see.
Level 22.
Okay, cool.
I can get a lantern.
All right.
Okay.
Uh, now I can see.
Oh, wait.
Has anybody done Bushi yet?
Bushi?
No.
Okay.
Is he even one of the things?
I'm gonna go attempt it.
Yeah, he is.
Yeah, I'm gonna go attempt it.
All right, I'm power leveling.
Okay, I saved a lot to power level.
I just need...
Oh, I'm all out of arrows.
That probably won't be a problem.
Oh yeah, sure for you can kill the Mamo swine too, because
we need the meat to make a steak.
Yeah.
Okay.
Shit.
Go pinking, go.
Get him.
Oh my god, my pinking is so small.
Just a little guy.
He's just a little guy.
Oh, true.
Fucked up, man.
It's not about the size.
It's about the power.
Look at him.
Yeah, but you're size shaming him right now.
He's dominating.
Okay, I'm gonna kill you.
Let's see.
We have the five traps for the Lambos yet?
Uh, no.
I was waiting for the ingot to be made.
Oh, okay.
Because our lazy fire Pokemon don't want to do it.
I can stay in bays till the ingots are done.
Because we need 25.
We need 25 to make the traps.
Because you need five for trap.
Like this- If you're doing bear traps.
Bro!
There's other traps!
Walking around!
Just make another furnace too.
Make another furnace.
Yeah, we can make another furnace.
Yeah, I feel like we could- we could count it with a lot of
time.
Okay, level 25.
I need five more levels for my chicken.
See?
Get over here, Lambe.
Alright.
I'm getting the Gigosphere ready.
What?
That's my ball.
Why are you coming for me, dude?
No.
Stay away from me.
Get over here.
I need as many fucking chickens as I can.
I need to be level 30.
I have no arrows, but this is fine.
That's fine.
I probably need arrows.
Or chicken nuggets.
okay get over here little cat oh he's dead why the heck i
where where is you going dude she's going on an adventure
what the heck wait she's like five bases away what why is
she okay let her live she doesn't want to be with you she
doesn't want to be with you anymore let me help you find
your place at the fucking place
Oh shit, have fun.
I literally have one fucking job.
Ryan!
Traps.
We can just make a...
Does it have to be a bear trap?
Or can it be a hanging trap?
It has to be a trap.
It just says...
Petalia's been caught.
Wait, clip, clip, clip, clip, clip, clip, clip, clip, clip.
Yeah, it's just traps.
Any traps work.
Okay, then we can just make a hanging trap.
We need five of them, so 50 what?
Bushi has been caught!
Clip, clip, clip!
Nice, yeah.
Alright, I'm out.
Let's go!
There you go, three in a row.
Alright, Bushi down.
I'm gonna head back to...
uh, base, and then I'm gonna go to the other dungeon.
How much time do we have?
Uh, 48 minutes.
Okay, easy.
Oh wait, I'll go find the entrance.
Screenshots at one point.
Yeah, yeah, we can do that in the last one.
30 minutes i have the reincarnated guy like uh uh marked i'm
putting these spheres in a chest yes i need them to catch
the humans later oh yeah we need okay do we have is do we
only have like two humans because i like i said i have two
all right i'm coming back to base and i can check i'm fast
traveling all right got a couple as well but they're a low
level so that'll I know that I attacked some, but I don't
know if I caught them.
Alright, let me check.
Get over here, your little cat.
Get over here, I'm going to kill you.
Alright, uh, the people I have...
I have...
None, none over 10.
Alright, then yeah, so you just need three, Lily.
Nice.
I think that's easy.
You just gotta go to the world that has three.
That's really it.
Okay.
all right let me make my van worm saddle oh no oh where is
the van worm saddle there we go all right i need ingot
fucking ingot okay you think oh we don't have time to breed
the anubis anymore though but that's a global thing we can
do that that's global yeah we should started that right now
let me see what we need to make the breeding shed yeah we
start catching the stuff okay
Uh...
Speeper...
There.
Okay.
Alright, let me see what it takes to do.
Um, the breeding.
Stupid penguin, you think you're strong.
Breeding, breeding, breeding, breeding.
Alright, I am at levels 26.
I need four more levels now.
Where's the breeding?
Did you get Fangalope?
Fangalope?
Nope.
I don't think Fangalope's in there.
No, it's not.
It is.
Oh, it is.
Yeah, it is.
Yeah.
I'm just catching the level 30 for the chicken now.
Oh, I see it.
It's level 19.
Okay, for the breeding farm, we already have everything we
need, so I'll just make it.
Yeah, just make it for now.
Okay.
I'm going to put it down in the area with, like, the trees
that we don't usually go down.
Okay.
don't okay my bird stop killing them all right get my
vanworms handle and then i'm good to go and i can go scout
yes finally flying mount yay it took way longer than it
should have that was really oh let's see i need like i'm
almost close to oh my vanworms hungry eat wait eat i can
fast travel eat everything i kill oh hey creamy okay all
right fast travel to the bridge and then from there i'll fly
no no i almost launched myself in the air mountain stream
grotto though is level 29 are we gonna be okay i mean
there's four of us well i mean i think what's fine just dug
it down like as As long as Strip 4 here, Strip 4 can, like,
fucking tank everything for us, too.
Yeah, it should be fine.
To tank?
Yeah.
All right.
Go in.
As long as we find a dungeon, we just need to find it.
Okay.
I'm going to try my luck this way first.
We got this.
This is going to be easy.
All right.
We caught five lamb bolts.
I'm going to go catch the humans now.
Nice.
Wait, flip the traps?
Yes.
Do you clip?
Clip, clip, clip?
Wicked.
Where's our clips?
And clippers?
Okay, we gotta keep going more and more north.
Oh, sure for it.
Kill a mammoth one.
The stake is 150 points.
Do it, do it, do it.
Is that day one?
Can anyone cook it?
Yeah, yeah.
Wait, what level do we need to be to cook it?
Any level?
Yeah.
Shouldn't be any level?
Find me a mammoth.
Um, spawn.
Find you a mammoth.
There's one in the starting zone.
Yeah, there's a boss one.
That one is the boss one.
Oh, um...
He was just gonna kill the boss.
Wait, I can't...
I saw a couple of one near me.
At the start, isn't that one of the bosses?
Yeah, that's one of the bosses, so...
I think I know where a couple of men are at spawn.
I forget that.
Yeah, I've seen some too.
Multiple clips that count towards it.
If I didn't catch them fast enough to make it all just in
one clip, I guess.
Sure.
I'm near the waypoint, which means there could be a dungeon
entrance over here somewhere.
Oh, non-boss one can spawn near the boss.
Okay, I'm trying to catch these other motherfuckers, though.
Are you serious?
They're all dead.
That sounds like a lot of guns.
I'm going to fly them out of here.
I'm too strong.
I have a mookal for breeding since we need milk.
I found the entrance.
We found the entrance here.
for the dungeon yep oh okay are we all ready to go let me
let me let me join because then we can catch the humans in
there yeah yeah probably over level 10 actually there's
humans over here and they're a level 7 oh okay 22 there's a
level 10 human i'm literally surrounded all right i'm
heading over now the dungeon is still around for another 98
minutes so i'm good i'm heading like are we all ready to go
sheriff are you ready oh shit oh okay okay where's the
dungeon i need to back anyway where i am where's pp okay
yeah i can make it then reasonable time there's so many
humans here whose giga spears is this mine yours okay don't
say i need those for the high level okay here i'm helping
you craft them take your where are you it's killing the
bontari alpha
I'll go make my own.
Okay, I have one level 10 human.
How many did we need?
No, they're all dying.
They're all being killed by random pals.
Oh, fuck.
Oh, no, he's dead.
Oh, wait.
They're not being killed by random pals.
They're being killed by my pals.
Stupid.
Oh, no.
Nice.
You're doing your part.
I want to see what it is.
And here I can...
What the fuck?
Oh, Ben, we're really okay?
My game crashed.
There's still more people over here, though.
Somewhere around here.
I have two level 10 heroes.
There's like a crap ton of like the Pal Alliance devout
people.
Wait.
We don't have the clip of the traps in our team thing.
Did we do it?
I thought Lily did.
Oh, okay.
PP mod.
Trap!
Can we track down that clip?
Oh, they did it.
They just did it.
It's rocked down the clip.
Okay.
They just did it.
I called them out and they did it.
Amazing.
Okay.
Well, it's not great.
No, that's not what I wanted.
Fuck.
One of the right is dying.
I only caught one.
That's fine.
We just need two more.
Okay.
I'm trying to catch this level 22 human.
Oh, no.
He did not want to be caught, I guess.
Okay.
Wait, can someone, like, clip the two humans I caught?
Because we have to compile all of them together.
Do we have a Kingpaka?
I don't think we did.
Yeah, I'm going to catch a Kingpaka while we wait, then.
Someone, can someone clip the two humans I caught?
I don't know where.
Oh, we guys screenshot them in the PAL box.
I just caught a level 22 human.
Can somebody clip that?
Nice.
Clip, clip, clip.
Where the fuck is the Kingpaka?
Where are you?
uh king kaka is near our base yeah i know i flew the wrong
way
all right let me see if there's any other humans around
uh how much time we got left uh 38 okay um i might fly back
and put stop in the incubator have you marked it i have some
guys in the incubator oh okay i just picked up a large dark
i A huge fire egg and a huge dragon egg in there.
Oh, dragon!
Let's go!
And I'm pretty sure it's the fire dragon.
Dingus?
Yeah!
That's the best one.
That's literally the best pal.
Fucking black and red Gyarados looking.
Okay, there's more people over here.
There's more human beings over here.
I'm gonna try to catch a couple.
Come on, Van Worm, you got this!
Oh, shit!
Not the one!
a rush bore.
A random rush bore.
I can catch him, though.
Alright, we're just going to keep throwing balls at him and
see if we can catch him.
No!
Wait, is that it?
Yeah, let me get a... Oh, he's fucking dead.
Oh, no.
He's a corpse.
Can't catch him.
He is dead.
The wild pals are killing him before we can.
It's the human?
It's kind of wild.
Yeah, I mean, that's why you can catch the pals and the
human at the same time.
Yeah.
All right, should I come back to base or are we ready to go
to the dungeon?
Go back to base because Shireforce's not ready yet.
Ido.
He's doing catching stuff, right?
Sounds good.
I need more hyperspheres.
These are high-level mobs.
Tell them to stop taking their riddle in.
That's how you get hyperspheres.
Come on, Grinto.
Why is the boss not spawned?
Did someone catch this guy?
Which one?
Fangalope.
Fangalope?
I don't know.
Then you caught him?
You caught him.
No?
Yes, you said you caught a Fangalope, didn't you?
No, because it doesn't say on the map that I did.
Oh, I thought you caught him.
Did you sound like me?
Did I catch him?
Did someone kill him?
What does the Fangalope look like?
I don't remember.
It's on me on the map.
Oh.
I thought you caught the No, I've never even been over there
before Yay, I caught the Kingpaka We have a bug Nice,
Kingpaka, clip it Clip, clip, clip, clip Clip, clip So what
are we supposed to do?
Are we gonna get complimentary points for that?
We skip it for now?
Question mark?
Sometimes he thaw through the door floor and dies Oh,
sometimes he just dies.
Okay, well I better get half points for trying All right,
clip it.
Half points for trying.
That's what I'm saying.
Oh, no.
My game is broken.
Why is it like this?
Okay.
What the heck?
All right.
I made an egg.
I made an egg chest.
So if you have eggs, please put them in there.
All right.
Yeah, no problem.
Does everyone have a flying pet so we can get to that one
island?
Yeah.
Yeah, my money's dead right now.
Wait, why do we need to go to the island?
Put that motherfucking hospital because that one place that
we need to take a screenshot is an island.
Oh, yeah, yeah, we can.
Yeah, we can do it the last, like, 20 minutes or something.
We're almost at the last 20 minutes.
Oh, yeah, we're okay.
Yeah, that's 35 minutes.
Let's do the dungeon first.
All right.
I'm on my way.
Okay, I'll go back to the dungeon then.
These guys, I need to kill them.
Are you close to a fast travel?
I don't know.
Oh, pales are hungry.
I think we have no food.
That all's starting.
I'm putting food in right now.
Whoops.
Yeah, because none of them were, like, transporting anything
to the thing, so they've run out of food.
All right.
Big oof.
I'm heading over.
I'm heading over to the base.
Let's go get ready.
We just need sure if we're to find a fast travel boat so he
can get to us.
okay because i'm just found one i'm flying over yeah i'll
just follow pp okay um the best fast travel spot is up here
at the ancient ruins if you can make it up there all right
uh the bridge is also fine though i'm heading over to pp and
there's uh humans here high level humans here if we want to
catch them how do we how many more do we need for humans i
mean i caught i have one so here.
No, these are level three.
Where's the cave?
Head to Pee-Pee.
I'm on her.
Okay.
We're flying over right now.
Oh, we killed them all.
Except for this one.
Actually, I'm going to use the wolf.
Actually, the wolf should be faster.
Nice.
Not nice.
Oh, fuck.
Did you guys kill?
Did you guys kill the humans?
No, there's plenty of more with that.
Look, I can't say that in front of without my lawyer
present.
Let's not comfortable speaking on that issue.
Oh, there's a human here.
No, I'm not going to kill it.
Well, the dungeon's right over here.
Yeah, I'm heading over.
Oh, there's one more Free Panel Alliance devotee.
I can probably get him, maybe.
Oh, there's a couple.
Actually, there's a couple.
uh if anybody has the nice spheres they might have a better
chance of getting them i'm almost there okay are you close
to dungeon yeah i mean right in front of it oh okay okay i
caught another one clip it clip it clip it he was level 17.
level 17 so we need two more right yeah no we need one more
wasn't it one more yeah one more yeah yeah uh there was one
but i just killed it so he's he's no good all right i'm here
wherever you are what the fuck wait where are you i'm right
here oh god attacked by like everything so i need one of my
chatters gave us the huh uh one sec your chat needs you cute
your chat do you uh someone's saying we can just build one
of the pal bases in that area and then just teleport to it
but i don't know oh true but we already have two pal bases i
mean wait you can just dismantle it anyways get in the
dungeon i'm here now are we all here We're going to dungeon.
Yep.
Wait, I'm not in the dungeon yet.
I need to finish catching this one real quick.
Okay.
Wait, where are you trying to catch?
A glider.
Yes, only one person needs to go over there.
Where is he going?
He's just...
And you can dismantle my base.
Yeah.
Well, okay.
I guess we're going in.
All right.
She's in Brazil.
Let's go.
Hope I don't crash.
He's just fucking going.
Don't crash.
All right, let's go.
We just need one human anyway.
We're flying, right?
Okay.
Is one of us catching the one human?
I have a couple balls, but I probably have the lowest
chance.
Does anyone know which is the boss room for this one?
I don't remember.
Do not remember.
Chairford, do you remember?
Probably.
We'll wait for him.
What if I catch it?
Oh, there's bees coming from here.
Don't we need to catch these?
The bees.
I don't think it's the bees.
We need the little two cans that blow up.
Oh, I have two.
I have two for breeding.
For breeding.
We need the queen.
It's not the bee guards.
It's the queen.
I think they have what it takes to make unmovies.
Shit, shit, shit.
The ping!
It's okay.
I got away.
Okay.
Ow.
Oh, that's a human.
Okay, it's not to the right.
Okay.
Oh, that true hard level.
I cannot catch those.
Straight.
Ah.
Oh, shit.
uh which way did we go usually it's water oh okay it's fine
no oh shit okay yeah it's right here okay okay wait wait
wait give me a sec guys let me catch the hot cat bitch all
right take a time give me a sec i'm trying to catch this b
guard real fast get it get it it's the hot one No, fuck
this.
I don't have enough.
That's what I just said.
No one's fucking listens to me.
She's making me question Who?
No one ever listens to the flesh tuber.
I'm sorry.
What did you say?
I'm sorry?
I didn't worry about it.
No worries.
You were saying sorry.
Okay, I'm here.
We're gonna let's go.
Go.
Are we using Giga?
Does anybody have Giga?
I only have a minute.
Yeah, sure.
I'll use Giga.
Not a lot.
I wish I had a lot.
He has just enough.
all right he's frozen it's a she she's frozen but maybe it's
a he you never know yeah maybe he's just trying to express
himself you don't know it doesn't say there's no there's no
male female sign on there I I want it to be a female let
your imagination run wild There's Pokemon, Batman.
We're at 30%.
Careful.
I'm retrieving my pal.
My pal is retreated.
Oh, first try?
First try?
Hey!
Clip, clip, clip, clip, clip, clip.
Clip, clip, clip.
Nice, nice, nice, nice, nice.
You want to know what I called Batman?
I caught a little punny, Batman.
all right we got another dungeon we should take a photo of
the reincarnated guy now since we're all here okay yeah
where do we get get the get the he's not he's not over here
get the get the person get the person he's a little he's a
little 17 he's a catch catch him catch him catch him oh 21
too i'm gonna help he's freaking running no somebody's gonna
oh this one's gonna get killed okay i can i catch him i
would get good okay i think it went into your ball anyway
which is It's fine.
It's fine.
I can still try and catch that.
I have 35 attempts.
Do you have them?
Clip, Clip, Clip!
We have all of it.
Clip, Clip, Clip, Clip, Clip.
We have five.
We have five humans.
When do we have to put them in jail by tomorrow?
By tomorrow.
It's a global.
Okay, okay, okay, okay.
Clip, Clip.
Do we need more humans or we could?
I don't know, actually.
I mean, we could get them later.
Let's grab the fast travel and then...
uh and then we do the reincarnated guy photo follow me
someone fly to the base and make a base and then uh during
that i'll be trying to catch more thines okay i dismantle
your base right you mean you mean dismantle the second base
you can dismantle it from the map yeah i'm gonna dismantle
someone else to fly there while i'm trying to kill the other
bosses while i have time okay i'm trying to min-max i've
like you want me to dismantle your base now i can dismantle
it now I'm sure.
All right.
I'm dismantling.
Oh.
All right.
Dismantling now.
It's gone.
The mysterious guy is below the King Paca, right?
Yeah, I can.
I'll fly over there now.
Uh, let's see.
Should I follow?
Do all four of us need to be there?
All four of us have to be there.
Okay.
I'll follow then.
And then, like, below that is where...
that one faces i need to get to level 30 so after the photo
i need to take a picture and not after the funny like power
level to little 30 so my chicken can be level 30.
is that today or tomorrow today oh i'm only level i'm like
level 28 i need two more levels uh wait does it have to be
one person technically you took it most of the way can we
give it to can we give it to sure and then oh yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah different i'm gonna give you the level the chicken
to 30.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, teamwork.
Teamwork, teamwork, mainstream work.
Put it in the thing.
Okay, okay.
You start making the fucking ore.
Oh my goodness!
Oh my god!
Dang it!
That's character growth.
Alright, I'm putting it in the box.
You fucking power level the rest of this goddamn chicken.
Yeah.
Where'd you put it?
In the pal box.
But where in the pal box?
In the pal's in the base.
At the bottom.
the bottom is the chicken there's only the one there's like
there's 5 000 chickens what do you mean it's in the it's in
the party yeah it's working yeah dragon yeah he'll be at
level 30 in like a second then yeah like literally one
battle and it'll probably pop up all right let's go to the i
have the i marked the reincarnated guy just follow me okay
um he is oh my gosh okay go to are we flying there or we no
no no no they're at the fast travel i'm heading over there
yeah Okay.
Okay.
All right.
Fast travel.
Oh, no, I don't have that one!
Okay, that's all right.
I'll just fly there as fast as I can.
All right.
Am I going in the right direction?
Uh, kind of.
Just follow me.
I'm flying.
Everybody.
I'm going as fast as I can.
I don't have that fast travel point.
Oh, I can see it though.
I can see it though.
so it should be just follow me and then we can all take a
picture i found him when i was lost and drowning oh you're
talking about pizza guy reincarnated guy right here ah okay
okay okay okay i'm here i'm floying pizza guy
taking a picture in the dark don't worry i had my lab i have
my lab that's why he's there I swear.
Guys, I swear he's right here.
What the fuck is?
Oh, they're here for it.
Okay, we just need.
I'm coming.
We just need.
I'm at the water.
All right.
Oh, down on the shore, right?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I guess we can all get off here.
Pizza guy.
Don't worry.
I have the lamp, so he'll be seen on my end.
There we go.
Are we all here?
Yep.
All right.
I can't dismount.
The execs.
The spout.
Sad next to him?
All right.
Screenshot.
We're all here!
.
Let's go.
All right.
We're done.
Let's go.
Someone fly to the island and make the base, and I'm gonna
try and get more of the big boys.
Who has- Fly to which island?
The island where we need to take a picture.
If you're more clear, the wildlife sanctuary.
Wait, do I do this?
I don't know where that it is.
Anyone could do it.
I'm just gonna have- I'm not sure- I have to go kill the
bosses all right.
I'll go find the wildlife side.
Oh, you guys you guys go there's a picture There's a
screenshot.
Sanctuary Location I don't know where it is.
I'm gonna I'm gonna look it up in the in the docks.
It shows where it is in the docks There's an image there is
yeah, but on the map though.
Yeah, wait wildlife sanctuary.
Isn't that that that thing?
I found us the shore and you know it's like that it's like
that big That like big circular thing with the like little
outstretched dock right yeah yeah extreme southeast oh it's
okay I'm literally like I can head there right now okay yeah
it's like very very southeast I have enough materials for
this rock how many materials for a pal box not much you need
a palladium fragment eight wood three stone eight wood three
stone oh I got it there fine I'm heading over now oh we got
the stake on we got the stake we did did you kill Swine did
we cook it?
Do we someone said we already have it in the chest We have
shit what yeah, someone look I guess all right.
I'm flying back.
I'm flying back Before it's I'll cook it.
I'll cook it if we got it.
Oh, no, we still need it.
Never mind Oh, we got one guy find me a mammoth and I'll go
kill it.
Okay, I went the wrong way.
I keep flying the wrong way.
God damn it All right mammoth spotting duty right here.
What a fuck do those suckers spawn?
easy but then there's like another area i'm opening up the
wait no i shouldn't open up the huge dragon egg or this huge
scorching egg you should get the exp for that coming i'm
leaving it i'm heading okay we're actually not far from
another spawn point of those mammoths ignis right yep am i
heading to the right wildlife sanctuary i just want to know
what was the scorcher blaze how are you going over there Am
I heading towards the correct one, guys?
So now we can use that to cook, but you'll probably just get
stuck on everything.
Yeah, probably.
Alright.
You're not wrong.
I have no idea where the guy is, but I'm almost there.
Uh, how much time we got left?
We have 20 minutes.
Huh.
Are you, did you get the chicken to level 30?
yet sure for i'm working on it faster do it faster okay we
just have all right what else what else can be done in a
really short period of time that just bosses all the bosses
okay i'm looking for the mamma i'm gonna fight someone find
a mamma for the i'll fight king packa we haven't no i did i
oh okay i'm at oh there's a lot of strong pals here okay all
right where where where where where criminal activity
underway somewhere what does that mean what about the tower
boss did anybody fight her yet no none of us have one of the
dailies or is that is it i don't know it's a global it's a
global all right i'm making the pal box is it here I'm here
Am I Oh, I'm not supposed Am I, is this the wildlife
sanctuary?
I'm pretty sure you're there Is it like a weird?
Do we have to talk to a person?
If you look on the map, it should look really weird No, we
just have to take a picture on the island Oh, okay, I'm
good, yeah, come over here We can take a picture now Yeah,
give me a check Alright, I'm fast traveling I did it I have
to find the fast travel nearby just get no it's a base just
go to base yeah it's the base we set up a base there yeah
but i i'm not near any trouble oh you're not i'm gonna see
what else we can do uh criminal activity underway we need to
capture 10 toko toko's i have two toko toko's on the far
right side of the map usually unless they i mean if you go
to your pal deck it shows you where they spawn yeah yeah i
only have on me i think or one i have one on me only i guess
i'm gonna try doing the rest of the bosses after this the
chickens level 30.
screenshot screenshot clip clip clip clip clip
i'm waiting he did where's lily lily's coming over i'm
almost at the freaking fast track
and then we're good.
I'm on my way.
Now I'll go back to Mammoth.
No, back to Mammoth's line, I think.
Dude, how is something so big, so hard to find?
They're supposed to be everywhere here.
What the fuck?
Are you good?
I'm coming.
Oh, here, okay.
Now we're at the island.
All right.
Screenshot, screenshot.
We're at the island.
What the fuck?
Screenshot, screenshot, screenshot.
That's okay.
They're raiding us here.
We are the herd of wild animals.
Alright, I'll see you guys later.
I'm gonna go.
I'm gonna, I leave.
Hey, we got our...
Easy EXP.
Easy, easy, easy.
Alright, we got it.
I hope somebody screenshot it.
I left.
I'm gonna do the other bosses now.
Let's see.
Got 17 minutes left.
You got Bushi, right?
You already got Bushi?
Yeah, I got Bushi.
Bushi's done.
Damn it.
Okay.
I'll get the Doom mode then.
Oh, they're all dead.
Nice.
Okay.
We need to find the fucking map.
Oh my goodness.
Day inside.
The castorite is so high.
All right, we need one person.
Oh my god.
We need one person to focus on finding a mammoth swine for
sure for because that's like a hundred points doing that
right now oh my goodness stay in holy shit let me go get the
mammoth okay are we able to fight the the 38 the level 38
mammarist i feel like maybe if you do it together maybe sir
get it but
probably on the list hold on it doesn't look like it's on
the list not on list okay yeah it's not uh bobby would get
the meat to cook the meat is quite some points yeah we still
need to stay but i'm also trying oh i found a mammoth oh
maybe i can kill it we'll find out all right where is it at
it's on me okay on you on you or should i don't have
anything oh i've got nothing over there to catch it set up a
new pal box i mean i kept it easy it's making your mood i
dismantled the base so okay let me fucking look for this
make a new pal box if only i had hyperspheres oh no well you
don't need hyperspheres you need to be dead we just need
steak yeah but i was just trying to catch it anyways fair
enough i hear you i'm heading over i got it what What?
You got it?
I got it.
Wait, you already got it?
Oh, nice.
You got the steak?
Cook it!
All right, all right, all right.
I need to find a fast travel.
Or someone could come to me.
That's what I thought.
Impossible.
Okay.
All right, I'm gonna do a little bit of...
Go flesh, boy, go!
Did someone make a cooking pot or anything?
Yeah, I did, I did.
It's next to incubator.
Um, all right, I'm gonna...
What level?
What's this one?
Did anyone do the...
What's this?
Enter sealed.
Which one is this?
I think there's no fault.
No one did the felt bat, right?
Nope.
Okay, I'm doing the felt bat now.
Oh, that's my fucking fist.
Insufficient materials.
Why?
What are we missing?
Uh...
Oh, wait.
Cancel.
Okay.
Pal team is hungry.
You can't be hungry right now!
Oh, they're hungry!
Oh, I'm going to them.
I'll feed them.
No, my pal.
No, no.
My fucking pal is hungry.
Yeah, the one that's trying to...
Nope.
the fork up these mammoth steak yes clip clip clip well it's
not cooked oh okay someone has to make it get kindled i'll
go i can make it get kindled i'm at base okay no okay what
else is something we have 12 minutes what else is something
something we can focus on um just like doing the bosses I've
been doing so much farming.
I'm only 19.
I think like we could focus on like our base for tomorrow.
Like leveling up the bases for tomorrow.
Yeah.
There's a fucking raid?
Shadow Legends.
But I think our pals can probably handle it.
I believe in him.
We're in like a pretty low level area, so...
Please don't kill me.
I'm so scared.
Let me snack some quick XP.
Memoristic.
Wait, let me grab a Kindling guy.
Kindling guy.
Come here.
Stop fighting.
I don't care about these guys.
Holy shit.
I suddenly care about these guys.
I do care.
I care very much.
Holy shit.
Jesus.
All right.
Well, cool.
Thanks.
Oh, please catch him.
all right all right van worm you're gonna do kindling and
get the steak done on time
armor is damaged palace hungry there's so many things wrong
there you go working on prepping day two yeah yeah yeah
parsley
please Oh shit, Toko, Toko, Toko, Toko, I can get started on
the Toko, Toko, Toko, oh yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, get Toko.
Where are they on the map?
There's two different locations.
There's one area that spawns them that's in this lower level
area, but it's unreliable.
And then if you go to the desert, then you can get a lot of
them, but it's level 25, so I don't know.
Oh shit, yeah, I can't.
There is a lower level area around here though.
Guys, if anybody can get to me, there is a fellback.
I'm right out of POW balls.
Alright, hold on, hold on, hold on, hold on.
I will bring you... Oh, shit.
I can't bring you.
There's no balls here.
No!
All I have are the regular balls.
I'm dead!
It's dead?
No!
No, I died.
Oh, you died?
Okay, that's okay.
If you died, that's okay.
We can remedy that.
But... I thought I had enough POW balls to do this.
No.
more pal bro we have to craft some wait do we get the steak
shit yet steak is being cooked okay we only how many do we
have to cook just one um just one and that's 100 points it's
taking a while to cook but it's halfway done okay i need pal
boss i got my actual pal on it so it's um can i grab yeah i
need those i need these yeah grab them grab them grab them
wait it's it's done it's done oh okay clip clip clip one
done yeah we have one done one all right clip clip clip clip
I think you have to clip shies because by the time I walked
over there was nothing on there but yeah I'll put it in the
in the in the thing so I can't just clip you opening the
chest okay true true true what do we what do we need left
other than the bosses we're at three minutes left oh my gosh
I'm gonna try and clash this in three minutes yeah yeah cuz
like We have to report it.
No, we have eight minutes yet.
We have eight minutes.
Why was the five minute report stuff?
Okay.
Here, Chad, you can clip this.
Memo steak right there.
Blah, there you go.
Oh, okay.
Okay, we have aim, okay.
All right.
Okay.
What are your stuff are we missing?
Treyf, are you done anything that hasn't been clipped yet?
I mean, I've clipped a bunch of stuff, but I haven't
submitted anything.
I don't know.
Oh, yeah.
What have you not submitted?
I don't know.
I just asked them to clip and then I move on.
Wait, what is it?
What did you do?
Fuck it, they're in the clips.
I don't know what to tell you, man.
But what does it mean?
Oh my god, they killed him again?
Okay.
Thought I didn't have to.
Okay, I'm gonna see if I can do this again.
I'm gonna make more powballs just in case.
Uh, just kidding.
No, I'm not.
We don't need fucking it.
I think I'm gonna make more ingot.
I didn't do this in seven.
There's no way you got I'm trying to do as much as I can in
the small amount of time I have Where what is your mission
right now?
Fucking killing the bosses.
What do you think man?
Well, how many bosses have you done?
Fucking like six seven.
I don't know.
Oh shit.
Do we even clip seven?
I'm sure for his bosses They're in the clips Can we see what
the clips after still?
No, no, we have to report them while We have to report them
If you can check, uh, SureForce Clips and see what has been
clipped and match it to anything that we've done, that'd be
great.
Thanks.
We need to make sure we got everything.
That'd be great.
Thanks.
Oh my god.
Please leave me alone.
Alright.
Where are you at?
Oh, you're way out there.
Never mind.
Good luck.
Godspeed.
way yeah I'm really far gonna get some lift monk statues
just keep making all of us do if we all get the lift monk
statues if we all get to level 10 like tomorrow say um do
all of us need to or just one person um it's per player yeah
per person okay yeah yeah okay please kill him please don't
please oh clip clip clip i got the clip clip clip let's go i
got the bat i got the bat okay we i can i can do like i can
do one more boss i think let's go i don't think i don't need
to care about my armor i don't think i need to care about it
don't worry about it okay i can get the doom mud the doom
mud is like right here
we need to start submitting yeah if we haven't already been
submitting uh well i think there's a time frame where you
can just submit okay pressure i think my mods have probably
been submitting the whole time so thank you mods okay okay
big appreciate
no the hit me where the is do mod Oh my god, there's too
many trees.
At least have this fast travel.
Okay, one tokotoko.
So much.
All right.
Oh my goodness, what is that catch rate?
Just stay in.
It's 30%.
It's not a bad.
You did like 12 balls.
I won 30% catch rate tokotoko.
What do you mean, wrong way?
I don't know where I am.
Tocco things.
Okay, I only have six balls left.
Make them count, I guess.
East.
I'm heading east.
Wrong island!
I went on the wrong island.
My fat ass bird.
Apparently I went on the wrong island.
No!
You think I can fight this Elfidrant?
Do I even have balls?
No, I should.
Wait, no, we Tony already fought him, didn't they?
which one Elphidrian Elphidrian I don't think so Oh for real
Oh but I probably can't catch it I only have normal ass
pal-balls Shit Is this it?
Shit That fucking sucks It's this way okay What the Four
minutes?
No way I can catch the doom The doom is my last hole I can
kill him You know what We'll try We'll try Whatever Let's
just try What's the worst that could happen Right?
We got four minutes Let's see if I can catch him in my
normal-ass pal-ball.
What's the worst that could happen?
Oh, my van worm could die.
That could happen.
Amory, please.
Why are you hungry?
Uh-oh.
He's targeting me.
No!
Okay, well, I'm dead, but that's okay.
I don't have the balls to catch the freaking to-co-to-co,
man.
You got this, Lily.
I believe in you.
I love the balls.
I have three balls.
We need, like, eight more the three balls it's gonna count
make those three balls worth it
all right yeah all right i'm gonna go back i need to at
least get my stuff so i start tomorrow with my stuff
bruh we didn't have any balls okay we can make some balls
now it's not gonna matter though i don't know i got i got
the worst sect i don't know how many bosses i got out of
time you got you got parsec just gonna grab my stuff for a
sec clip clip clip clip clip clip clip all right hopefully
someone submitted the clips i don't know thanks mods i don't
know that's it's okay do much get over here the last 10
points right here let's go
fucking min-maxing?
Yeah, it was too hard.
It was worth a try.
I wanted those toko-toko-to-toos.
But then I had to use, like, five trillions of balls on one.
Please, please, no.
That's a lot of balls.
That is...
Do mine!
I got two more clips!
I got two more!
Nice!
We got...
MVP!
Okay, how many minutes do I have left?
Like none?
Oh, one minute.
Okay, that's it.
Yeah, I got the one we needed.
got the 110 the 110 we'll still get half i've never even
seen a 14.
all right do we have everything that shore floor got though
i think so maybe run down the list can we double check and
because we can report stuff that's to double check
everything let me check the channel what clips we got
because we have five minutes to like report everything okay
okay okay okay all right we have the steak yep steak photos
no we already reported a chicken the level 30 chicken my mod
said they think they got most but maybe we should run down
the list yeah run down everything sure for do you remember
how many you've caught can you like name it off at the clips
you can also just look at the pile box and then be like hey
true this clip ding ding okay i got the broncherry was
bugged relax source lux beacon and patellia and warsect so i
got one two three four five hey and then you got the chicken
to level i would have gotten six if the fangalope wasn't
bugged did you get the did we clip the chicken already i'm
gonna look at the i took a screenshot
uh oh they missed aqua okay they Mr. Aqua.
Did you get the chicken?
They said they haven't gotten the chicken to 30 screenshot
yet.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, I got to put a post in the screenshot.
I think this is the screenshot.
See, level 34 chicken right there.
Level 32.
Dang.
They're level 32 chicken.
That we have all the humans.
Like, once we put them all the humans.
There you got that.
So we got the fun achievements.
Did we got the level 12 base?
Is it in there?
Wait, did we take a photo?
I don't think we did.
I don't think so.
Oh, no, we did.
We did.
We level 12 base.
Yeah.
Cool, cool, cool, cool.
Um, I caught the chillit, the sweet pea, the gumaz, the
doomut, the peaking, the azurobe.
Let's see.
Uh, azurobe, penking, quivern, uh, king, uh, king paca, The
Felbat and the...
Yeah, that's all the bosses I took out.
And I have two Shinies.
The Flock and the Lamber.
Because we have, like, the shiny thing, right?
Yeah, we have two Shinies.
We got two Shinies.
We got two Shiny points.
Oh, and then...
Well, we have our Registered Pals.
How many Pals do we have registered?
Let me see.
Isn't that a global event?
Or is that per day?
Well, it's global.
But doesn't that add it up?
Doesn't it add up to us?
the very end of the event because all you do is look at your
pal deck and see registered i have um i have 41 i have 39
registered we're are we doing the is it the encountered or
is it the registered it's registered yeah i have 39
registered registered nice uh 31 registered i don't know if
it's like does it count to uh okay what's my statue of power
I didn't even check I didn't even level it up okay I managed
to get three toko toko's we don't have by chance I have four
no we didn't we don't level two power oh points per player
is zero okay never mind uh
wait did the Lyft monk matter today or tomorrow that's
tomorrow that's global okay okay all right that's global
Yeah.
Yeah, to hold off.
And we can still do day one and day two.
Yeah, and tomorrow the EXP multiplier is going to be 20.
It's going to be quiet.
It's going to be kind of wild.
Let's see.
The only thing...
So we did...
Yeah, did we...
Did we report all the ones we captured?
Oh, log out.
Oh, I forgot to log out.
Oh.
Log out.
Oh, shit, we have the...
Yeah.
Walk out.
Thanks.
Thanks for the reminder.
Did the mod cut...
Did the mod cut all of it?
Did the mod cut all of our palace that we captured?
Chill, sweet, Kumas, Dumud, Pen King, Azuro, Grintel,
Broncherry, right?
We got Broncherry, Kempaka, Bushi, Quivern, Felbat, yeah.
What else?
battalia bon cherry aqua you got both bon cherries just bon
cherry aqua I'm pretty sure oh just bon cherry okay bon
cherry aqua war sack relaxesaurus is that over them
relaxesaur at who's our mod what's the mod's name at
overlord did you get all of them did you close the server uh
I logged out I locked out.
I don't know if that closes or not.
I think we have everything.
The server.
We need Gumas clip?
Guys, where's the Gumas clip?
Which one is Gumas?
Oh, I didn't do Gumas.
I did.
Well, I had a screenshot of Gumas.
If you have a screenshot, that should be enough.
Someone has the Gumas clip.
There you go.
If you can put it in the chat.
Boom.
Nice.
Yeah.
Alright, that should be everything, right?
Okay.
We...
Now we die.
Now we...
Okay, now we're done.
That's all five minutes.
That's it.
I just saw my mod DM.
It's got like 200 messages.
Mod, how could you not get the Goombas clip?
I worked so hard on getting that Goombas.
We got all the fun achievements.
Yeah.
We did.
We're having fun.
Except for the Tokos.
But that was on mute.
Eh.
They never enough balls.
What placement did we get in the end?
Guys.
Are they still calculating?
I think they're still calculating.
We sent stuff for so long.
I'm pretty still calculating.
Yeah.
Well, at least now, though, now we know what the
achievements are.
So we can strategize for how we want to start day two.
And like, what the plan is.
We're on 10th place right now.
All right.
That's how much money that's not bad I don't I don't know if
they're like finished calculating though.
That's a thing I don't know they finished calculating.
All right, that is Hey, that's a hundred eighty seven
dollars.
Let's go
The ranking also includes global points not last let's
fucking go.
We broke top ten Let's go top ten we still have time we
still have time well how are we gonna do tomorrow um i can
finish the day one i'll i can finish like all the day one
easies okay um uh and then short for can work on the other
day ones that we missed let's see all right day two cook a
mozzarella cheeseburger i think we already have any of our
registered pals in yet so that's not in the scoring either
yeah I think looking at how many points we get for tomorrow
we should probably do the leftover only if we have nothing
better to do because we only get half points for the day one
and day two gives like already five times more baseline for
similar difficulty for some it seems kind of like what we
might want to do is we might want to just do whatever we can
to power level sure to level 50 so we can get a towel up to
level 50 and then we can take on just pat catching towels
yeah yeah just making balls um i think i'll just make a ton
of balls because like we've been struggling all day yeah
yeah we need more yeah okay yeah i think i'll just stick
around in base make sure they actually work and make let me
let me check on all of the i'll like make a list after this
of all the materials that we need to get to base level 20
yeah like just in total um because we're gonna have to have
uh probably sure make all of the items because they're gonna
start into the high level stuff but i will check and see
what we need i'm sure we're gonna start needing things like
like coal and stuff so all right yeah so okay legendary pal
how take a photo with a lift monk energy inside the volcano
okay easy easy uh take a photo at the top of the astral
mountains easy second wildlife sanctuary easy yeah those are
we can get that in the last hour the photos always easy we
just have one person build bases and stuff yeah yeah so the
strat worked well because then one can just stay back and
make balls and they have like no waypoints but it doesn't
matter because we need to rush our hot dog a rush or hot dog
so we need to kill one of those and then a mozzarella
cheeseburger i think i'm gonna see what's in the moderna
cheeseburger because we already have a whole bunch of milk
so i think we already have tons of milk i think oh that's
right my z key doesn't work anymore sureforn you need to get
to level 50.
that should be fine on the multiplier as long as balls yeah
you need level 50 and because you need to get paled at level
50 or you can just get hard on the balls and the level of
cheeseburger yeah requires oh we need an electric kitchen
that's the problem we have all this stuff for it but we need
to be level 41 sure freaking like power level fast uh and I
guess like I can I'll start power leveling as well so I can
help out with catching the stronger powers like the Verdash,
Memorus and the Violet, and then Chifor can work on the hard
ones.
Yeah, I'll probably keep management of inventory, and then
once the base is at level 20, I'll just go back.
We need to work on the breeding stuff as well.
Yep.
Okay.
I think you just do a base management, I'll just craft
bolts.
The base management, a lot of it is going to be just making
sure we have enough stuff, and then once we do, being like,
okay, come back sure so all right uh come back craft then
yeah come back please make this thank you all right um yeah
breeding okay figure that out okay i'll take breeding and
base management for tomorrow good and the balls and and the
materials be spam capturing so i guess i guess cooking too
because cooking is also just really yeah yeah apparently we
can get 700 points for petting huh we need 700 points if we
fight but we need to catch every type though oh there's so
many we probably already do have every type though we need
water grass dark ice earth fire electric dragon the hardest
one is dragon and we have dragon yeah oh okay so we're good
we're good already let's see i'm just checking They haven't
they didn't count our chicken.
We worked so hard on the chicken.
What do you mean?
They didn't count our chicken.
Why not?
Tell me about my fangalope being bugged.
I can't believe it.
Wait, why didn't the chicken count?
What the heck?
When it says padding different pals of the same element,
does that mean that we need to have four of the same element
pal in the same screenshot?
Maybe.
Because that's what it looks like in the photo.
I guess all four of us.
Yeah, all four of us pet like different ones.
Okay, so we need four dragons.
Yeah.
flying wavering thing isn't that one a dragon we're all
teammates are paying different pals of the same element so
uh we just need to make sure we're all petting the same one
okay oh oh all right i love different pals the same i got
pals all over my shit yeah i guess that's it right i think i
think so until tomorrow yeah until tomorrow and then we
fucking grind our shit out all right we got 10 plays let's
go Day one, testing!
Hey, 10 boys!
Not bad!
Top 10!
Trust the process!
I think we're higher too because we don't have our pokey
deck points.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, trust the process.
It's full fucking AM.
I'ma bounce.
Bruh!
Go go sleep.
Oh my god, yeah, head to bed.
You guys have pictures?
Oh wait, they want pictures of the registered pals?
Oh, I have to log back in though.
Look at my...
Oh, I would have to log back in.
Okay.
No, we must have looked at our pal deck, right?
I can just log in really quick.
Oh, I mean on stream.
Yeah.
They said they want.
Oh, yeah You just got a picture.
I think I think I'm covering the Peldeck on stream.
No, let me check Wait, am I allowed to log back in?
I don't think so.
No, we have to you can.
I think we have it on our stream Do you guys guys have a
clip guys?
Do you guys have a clip?
Because you're asking us for it.
I said it out loud, but I there's no rewind on Twitch.
I mean, I could easily be like I have
like it's global so it doesn't matter right we can't get it
tomorrow it's just a it's a global yeah it's a global yeah
but if it means we get like not i guess okay we're not gonna
get like seven place never mind i'm gonna say what happens
if you're in the top whatever top what what do you mean does
it matter right now i mean it means it doesn't matter if
we're seventh place or whatever if we get to seven place
we're tenth place currently so like if we get to seven place
we just get more money.
On day one?
Yeah, on day one.
Yeah.
Oh, shit.
I mean, take the wallet if you can see the register
palettes.
But I'm pretty sure I'm covering.
I think it's like in the bottom left corner, isn't it?
When you open the paldex, I think I'm covering it.
I have no idea.
If we're allowed to log in real quick, I can check.
When we're opening the fucking paldex.
Yeah, I wish I could just open it.
Yeah.
oh my god can we ping a mod and just ask them if we can open
it yeah you can all right i'm just gonna ping a mod because
i don't think any of us had that yeah i know i have 39 i
like showed it on my end that we have 39 yeah i'm covering
i'm covering it with my model i mean you can't see it on
stream no i haven't opened but you can't see that's so
unlucky that's so unlucky wait who clip.
Does anyone have the clip of my 39?
Does anybody have a clip of my 32?
Does anyone have a clip of that?
What do you mean, V2?
If I was a face cam streamer, I would cover it too.
It's the same position!
What do you mean?
I mean, you could have put it on the other side.
I guess.
I guess so.
That's true.
Yeah.
Yeah, okay.
Yeah, okay, that's true.
Uh...
I got it.
Yeah, I only looked at it one time really briefly.
It's mine.
Yeah.
Apparently they're still calculating scores.
We're 11, man.
Who the fuck?
How?
What the fuck?
How are 11?
What happened?
What did I do?
Because they showed their registered pals.
Oh, they said no.
Oh, no.
Okay, well.
The slant phase.
Team Burn found eight.
lucky pals what the fuck they found eight wait did we show
our our lucky pals ma did you show my lucky pal yeah we have
two it counts as two yeah i don't know if i'm the mod showed
it though mod i worked so hard catch i swear to god i worked
incredibly hard yeah they did they did they got one i they
got what oh they got two thank god okay okay two two okay i
worked so hard capturing this try and find the clip of your
my mods are scrubbing the vod is not available what your
registered pals are non-available yeah damn it you can kind
of if you if you know where it is in the ui you can see 21
you know what you can do wait you know what you can do oh
wait that's right you were in front of it for mine i could
just stop the stream right now it'll create a vod and then
they can like yeah grab it do it do it hold the line hold
the line i'm stopping the stream for one second one hold the
line hold the line i have the i have the one
what oh wait they got it they got someone got it you're all
she already stopped your stream yes you can't see the 21 you
can't if you go into the what okay i'm making a clip if you
go here streaming what i didn't know that you can't see it
says 21 it's just you just don't see the sas capture but you
know that's the ui well they're gonna post it fuck it just
just post it Post it.
Post it.
It technically counts.
It counts.
Let me get it.
Dude, wild.
Thanks, Mox.
Well, I'm gonna go.
I need to go to the washroom.
Okay.
See you guys tomorrow.
Bye.
See you guys.
All right.
Are we all good?
Are we all good now?
I think so.
I'll come up with a plan for tomorrow.
Just double checking.
I'm on base cooking and breeding.
Yeah.
I'm just gonna power level and help I'm just gonna help I'm
power leveling and helping sure forward with capturing pals
I evolved into a trad wife over this stream I'm just gonna
take care of the house and the kids Oh my god Where the fuck
are they finding like Where are they find we're playing like
Twitch Twitch plays some random maze right now Where are
they finding like placements
Bro How do they know what the placements are?
Did we drop again?
No.
No, don't tell me that.
I don't want to hear it.
I just want to pretend to be top 10.
I want it.
I just want it.
I'm almost top 10.
That's almost like top 10.
Come on.
We're like 10 points.
Wait, we have 10 teams.
Wait, no, we...
It's like... It's still calculating.
It should have count.
Yeah.
Wait, but like does it count or you peek at it from behind
the hair Yes, you can see like I'm moving around you can see
it peek through like you can tell us what you want Yeah,
come on, you can you know it's it says it sounds captured.
You know that's it's really out of the you You know, no Give
us so 10 points You know it's like don't be weird mom
You can peek from, I'm watching the clip.
I'm watching the clip back.
It's like be more towards the end.
You can clearly see it.
It sounds 21.
Yeah.
Oh, yeah.
You can definitely see it.
Yeah.
I mean, bro.
Green shot of it.
We literally, okay, if we count all our, if we count our pal
register points, that's like 30 points and then we'll be
back to top 10.
Okay, hold on.
Oh, I got it!
I got it!
I fucking got it!
Okay, I got it.
I got it.
Here you go, here you go.
Yeah, let's go!
21 seconds.
21 chicken dinner.
Can you do something for me?
Come on.
I need to know our registered pals.
Wait, I'm gonna I'm gonna show chat how fucking clutch this
is.
Wait, let me save.
Let me save the actual video.
I'm just gonna save the video.
This is wild.
Bro, like, we have, like, more achievements than, like,
than, like, the two people who are 9th and 10th.
It's fucked up, man.
We just don't have enough power registered.
No!
It's our power registered.
We did so many achievements!
Fuck!
I hit the button.
Alright, I'll show you.
Alright, chat.
This is what we were working with it's because look at it
it's right there someone's like i'm confused how the team
had is in 10th place in the heavy it's because of pal
registered it's actually pal registered all right watch
watch we're gonna see that 21 oh oh come on take us to top
10 there it is come on there's the 21 clutch absolutely
clutch oh my god come on just
We're 10?
We're 10 again?
Are we 10 placing it?
We're 10?
We're 10 again?
No, it's not.
I'm looking at the achievement list.
No.
We are!
We're 10!
Yeah!
Let's go!
We got top 10!
Between the...
Let's go!
Let's fucking go!
Top 10!
Six other teams!
Nice.
Oh my god, nice.
Okay, I'm gonna- We did it.
We did it.
We fucking did it.
We did.
I think like the last 30 minutes we should like drop pals to
each other so we can like make sure we all have registered
pals.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Well, wait a minute.
I have a question though and maybe chat can answer this.
I'm pretty sure if you drop pals, does it register or does
it like not register?
Like do you actually have to catch it?
No, no.
It's just you just get bonus for catching you just have to
you just have to drop pals and then Uh, wait, you can't
register from dropping pals.
Really?
That's not okay.
I got lie to I got one missed opportunity right there.
I got I got I got one guy earlier.
All right again We're top 11th again.
Who keeps I refreshed it How somebody no top 10 top 10.
No, no.
They're like fucking around they're they're fucking around
right now They're like, ridiculous.
It's like every time you refresh, it's different.
I don't understand.
Every time you refresh, it's like the placement's changing.
The doc is being weird right now.
What do you mean, all done, thanks, guys?
What do you mean?
I don't understand.
Why does it keep changing?
It says we're top 10.
There's no way.
my god we were 20 points away from wait from nice place what
we were 20 points away from nice place 20 points away yeah
we were that close dude yeah the registered pals really
fucked us didn't it yeah we're you know what though you know
what though we're still pretty high we're pretty high though
we got so many achievements yeah we did well despite
struggling yeah we have like the Just a lowest amount of
lucky pals, though.
We just did not have luck.
I mean, I found that I was the only one that found lucky
pals.
We're traveling far and wide, man.
What do you mean?
I literally went to a fast travel and then it showed up
right beside me.
It was like waiting for you.
Yeah, it says we're in tent now, again.
Yeah, I'm on the actual one, not the...
Yeah, I'm on the actual one too.
It says we're 10 and it says they're done.
so i guess we got 10.
yeah top 10.
you know i take those i take top 10.
i take top 10.
yeah let's go top 10.
ggs guys i had a great time how does how does the team above
us have um 20 more points than us when their registered pal
is zero um they might they might have like wait you're right
what yeah honestly maybe they call it the hard ones like the
the uh you know like the pals at the bottom Wait, but
doesn't that just mean, doesn't that just mean that tomorrow
they're going to show their registered pals and then they're
just going to yeet themselves into first?
Guy and Rocket, yeah.
I don't fucking know.
Uh-oh.
Ruh-oh.
All right.
GGs, guys.
I'm going to go talk to my chat.
Thanks for...
I had a great time for day one.
GGs, thanks.
See you guys tomorrow.
GGs, see you guys tomorrow.
Those four hours pass by so fast.
Yeah, so fast.
It's so much fun.
Yeah, all right.
See ya.
Bye.
Alright.
Wow.
That was really fun.
I hope you guys had a great time.
I hope you guys had a great time with Shy Lily, Pee-Pee, and
Sure4.
Yeah.
Holy shit.
We were fucking gaming.
To be fair, we were a bit scum.
We had no plan.
Okay.
We had zero plan and we got top 10.
That's all that matters.
No plan, top 10.
Let's let it go.
But it's thank you all for the subs.
Thank you all for the subs, the gifted subs, for following
and all of that on Twitch.
Thank you guys so much.
And the bitties.
Thank you guys.
I had a great time with all of you.
I mean, we streamed for four hours.
Holy fuck.
Those four hours were intense.
I'm going to call it here because I want to make sure I have
enough energy for tomorrow because it's going to be another
four-hour day.
But thank you, everybody.
I hope you guys had a great time watching.
For those who are new here, I usually stream on the
YouTubes, so please check me out on YouTube.
I think, like, exclamation point YouTube, you can subscribe
to me there.
Sometimes I stream Twitch stuff like today because it was
Twitch Rivals.
And if you want to get more updates on when I stream on
Twitch, please check me out on Twitter.
I don't know if exclamation point Twitter works.
And merch!
Merch!
You're going to support me via other ways!
There is merch!
Exclamation point merch.
I will be putting up Lunar New Year merch.
I think like I'll have an announcement later on like
Saturday or like Monday or Sunday.
I think like Lunar New Year merch is going to come up on
Saturday or Sunday.
Anyway, I had an amazing time with all of you guys and I
hope you guys had an amazing time with my team and
everything.
Thank you all stay hydrated, pause your chair, get up and
move around to get that blood flowing.
And if you stay up for me, head to bed because you deserve
it.
I'll see you guys next time, everyone.
Bye, guys.
Bye.